Also bei Mt. Wir haben irgendwie 200.000 Bitcoin in der Ritze vom Sofa gefunden. Also bei Mount Gox, da war nie alles in Ordnung.
Vielleicht macht der Höhle sich an der Bank auf.
Nichts genaues weiß man nicht. Nichts genaues weiß man nicht.
Mount Gox waren für mich eigentlich die, die von Anfang an irgendwie dabei waren und die halt am größten und am stabilsten waren.
Der Trust Level ist jetzt nicht so hoch.
Der Trust Level bei Mount Gox, der ist glaub ich durch.
Ja, hat seinen Ruf weg.
Das ist echt ein geiler Laden. Nichts genaues weiß man nicht. Nichts genaues weiß man nicht.
Nachts geht es, tagsüber nicht.
Also von allen, wo es nicht Clemens macht oder andere Leute, die das können, ging es halt gar nicht. Ich habe dort so ein paar, so in der Ecke, wo niemand war, hingen noch so ein paar Base Stations, wo man dann, wenn man da in der Nähe war, dann ging es plötzlich. Aber so ansonsten war es nicht offline. Eigentlich war es so die ganze Zeit offline, ja. Und im Hotel war es aber okay. Jetzt nicht übermäßig schnell, aber okay. Und so ansonsten. Heizen tun sie ordentlich. Also wenn die Russen was können, dann heizen. Und dann wird es so ein bisschen wärmer. Und dann kannst du das Hotelzimmer nicht mehr betreten, ohne gleich das Fenster aufzumachen. Und was ich auch sehr geil fand, jeder Laden, wo wir rein sind, wirklich jeder Laden, einschließlich Kongresszentrum, hat so eine Garderobe, wo du als allererstes deine Jacke abgibst. Also die sind echt darauf vorbereitet, dass du irgendwie so im Thermo-Outfit da ankommst. Und das erste, was du tust, ist diese Hülle abschmeißen und irgendjemanden geben, dass er es auf dem Bügel tun kann.
Das ist so wie Regenschirme in Tokio. Also du hast in jedem Laden auch erstmal einen Regenschirmständer. Und da stehen dann auch immer Regenschirme. Du kannst ja auch einen nehmen.
Okay, das ist so ein Regenschirm-Communismus, wie der Feuerzeug-Communismus.
Ja, du nimmst ja einfach einen Regenschirm und benutzt den.
Und schmeißt den woanders wieder ab.
Ja, wie Car-Sharing. Regenschirm-Sharing ist das halt so.
Also Mantelsharing haben sie nicht gemacht.
Nicht so Sharing, aber der Bedarf ist einfach so klar. Und so, dass man da einfach so einen Modus finden muss oder zwangsläufig findet. Bin ich überrascht gerade rüber. Wahrscheinlich sind die einfach meistens da. Wann ist denn da mal warm?
Weiter unten ist irgendwo ein Klimadiagramm.
Klimatabelle Punkt 12.
Da siehst du halt so, im Juli Höchsttemperatur 26 Grad. Und im Januar Niedrigstemperatur minus 20. Das ist dann schon so.
Aber es geht ja noch.
Ja, es geht schon noch, aber die meiste Zeit oder ein halbes Jahr ist halt unter Null.
Aber gut, das ist die Durchschnittstemperatur.
Minus 12 ist die höchste Temperatur.
Im Januar ist minus 12 die höchste Temperatur, wenn es da mal einen sonnigen Tag hat.
Aber das sind die monatlichen Durchschnittstemperaturen, das heißt, das ist die maximale Durchschnittstemperatur.
Aber im Sommer auch dafür durchschnittlich 25, ja? Im Juli.
Na ja gut, das ist aber da, wo es bei uns dann 36 hat oder so.
Durchschnitt haben wir hier keine 36.
Na gut, Durchschnitt nicht.
Wahrscheinlich nicht mal 25, oder? Im Juli?
Na ja, es ist ein sehr kontinentales Klima. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass wenn es dann mal richtig warm wird, wird es auch richtig warm, aber hm.
Wieder live versorgt ihr vom Wetter-Podcast.
Wir vergleichen.
Keine Ahnung, aber man merkt, das ist schon so ein bisschen darauf ausgelegt.
Ja, es ist nicht so kalt.
Also da ist im Juli wärmer.
Da ist im Juli wärmer, ja, ein klein bisschen.
Zwei Grad ist ja nicht so wenig.
Ein klein bisschen. Und ich habe versucht, U-Bahnen zu fahren. Da gibt es nur U-Bahnen.
Im Juni ist es auch wärmer da. Bei uns ist es einfach besser gemittelt. Da ist es super extrem. Eines halben Jahres hast du da eine Schwankung von 30 bis 40 Grad im Mittel.
Guck dir das an. Das ist so inmitten des eurasischen Kontinents wie fast gar nichts.
Aber dann schüttet es auch wie Blöde im Juli und August. Das musst du auch noch mal mit einrechnen. Es ist zwar warm, aber es pisst auch noch die ganze Zeit, während es bei uns einfach trocken ist.
Da wird die Stadt vielleicht mal sauber.
Unsere? War die denn dreckig?
Ja, die war dreckig. Oder roter Staub? Dieser ganze Staub. Keine Ahnung, ob sich das über den Winter angesammelt hat. Und es war das erste Mal, dass Schnee weggeschmolzen ist. Oder ob es das Zeug reinzieht. Keine Ahnung. Ich fand diesen ganzen Staub und Dreck sehr auffällig.
Interessanter ist, dass für Novosibirsk auch noch die Anstahl der Sonnenstunden angegeben ist. Das haben sie bei Berlin komplett weggelassen.
Das wäre auch peinlich, glaube ich, für Berlin.
Auf Wunsch von Berlin-Partner gelöscht worden.
Ist nicht relevant. Leute machen doch eh Urlaub.
Sommer in Berlin, der schönste Tag im Jahr. So schlimm ist das Wetter hier gar nicht. Der Frühling ist spektakulär.
Dann habe ich versucht, U-Bahn zu fahren und das ist gänzlich misslungen, weil weder die Frau am Schalter Englisch konnte, noch konnte ich aus diesem Automaten, bin ich überhaupt nicht schlau geworden, hinterher. Er wurde mir dann erklärt, es gibt keine Zonen, man kauft einfach eine Fahrkarte. Und der Nummernblock an dem Fahrkartenautomaten ist nur, um anzugeben, wie viele Fahrkarten man kaufen will. Also es wäre eigentlich relativ einfach gewesen, wenn ich es gewusst hätte.
Einmal die Eins drücken und die Münze einwerfen.
Dann sind das nicht nur die deutschen Kids, die bei, wie heißt das? Dieser Schulstandard da? Beim Pisa-Standard durchfahren, weil die Automaten so schwer sind. Nein, Roddy ist auch durchgefallen.
Auf Kirillisch.
Ja, eins oder drei musst du auch hinkriegen.
Ja, schon, aber mir war nicht klar. Ich wusste halt nicht, muss man da jetzt irgendwie die Nummer von der Zone angeben oder weiß ich nicht, irgendwie gibt es...
Solche Sachen gibt es nur in Deutschland.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung.
In der Schweiz. Ja, und wie international war dieses Event?
Also von den Sprechern her, da haben sie schon versucht, relativ viele internationale Leute ranzukriegen. Also Microsoft war Sponsor irgendwie und sie hatten zwei Sprecher, glaube ich, von Microsoft, eine ganze Menge Leute von Google und ein paar eBay-Leute und dann halt so diese ganzen russischen Firmen, die man halt auch kennt, so diese Parallels und die Jungs, die App-Code machen, wie heißen die, diese Entwicklungsumgebung. Das sind doch auch Russen. Na egal. Also ja, also einigermaßen international. Sie versuchen relativ viele internationale Leute ranzukriegen.
Hat sich aber jetzt nicht angefühlt wie London oder Barcelona oder sowas.
Das war schon ein russischer Event. Also das war so. Nee, gar nicht mal so sehr. Also es gab nach dem ersten Tag gab es noch so einen Abschluss. Whisky, was irgendwie aus zwei riesigen Flaschen Jack Daniels Red Label bestand.
Weil die Microsoft dies mitgebracht haben.
Keine Ahnung. In so einem Halter, wo man die Flasche dann so kippen konnte, dass man sie nicht hochheben musste. Und dann haben sie so auf dem Tisch irgendwie ganz viele Gläser, also so Plastikbecher schon vorgefüllt, dass man sich nur einen nehmen konnte. Und daneben standen halt ganz viele Cola-Flaschen. Und die Leute haben irgendwie alle gewohnheitsmäßig dann die Cola genommen und da noch mit reingekippt. Und ich dachte mir so, nee, da kippe ich jetzt nicht noch Cola rein, das schmeckt eh schon schlimm genug. Also da brauche ich nicht noch Cola drin. Ja, keine Ahnung. Ich nehme mal an, dass man...
Leute, die schon länger im Programmierbusiness sind, die müssen sich halt mit Alk besaufen. Also ich meine, guckt ihr das Heartbleed an?
Aber in Russland, da hätte es ja hoffentlich auch einen ordentlichen Vodka gegeben.
Ich denke mal, dass man dem allgemeinen Russen nichts bieten kann, wenn man ihm einen Vodka hinstellt, weil das kennt er. Aber so ein Whisky hat wahrscheinlich noch so einen exotischen Wert. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht gibt es nächstes Mal Kassasser.
Ja, wenn die meisten Besucher sowieso nicht aus anderen Ländern sind, sondern aus Russland, dann gibt es da halt die ganzen exotischen Sachen. Jetzt haben wir auch ein Bierchen mitbringen können aus Deutschland oder so was.
Ich sage mal so, der eine Mexikaner von Google, der hat sich dann irgendwie so saufmäßig mit einem Russen angelegt. Interessanterweise, weil erstens war der Russe schon relativ breit und zweitens war der Mexikaner verdammt trinkfest, was irgendwie nicht gut ausging für den Russen. Das war sehr spaßig, aber dann irgendwie mit so, lauter nur so brennende Drinks. Also die haben dann irgendwie die Theke gewischt und dann haben sie so ein klebriges Zeug einmal so im Kreis aufgetragen und in der Mitte was nicht so klebriges reingeschüttet und dann brannte alles und dann musste man das irgendwie mit Stroh und Trinken und so weiter. Also es war alles sehr, ja...
Event-orientiert.
Don't try this at home, kids. Also, ich weiß nicht. Aber ich hab da nicht so viel gesoffen, also... Also ich war ja die Woche davor, also das muss man dazu sagen, ich war die Woche vorher in England bei der NS Conf und bei der NS Conf gibt es so ein inoffizielles Event. Jedes Mal, das nennt sich Whiskey Lab, findet auf einem Hotelzimmer statt von irgendjemanden. Und die Leute, die das schon länger machen, die versuchen sich immer gegenseitig zu übertrumpfen, indem sie einen guten Whiskey mitbringen. Und was da an Whiskeys auf dem Tisch stand, das war unglaublich. Also da war einer, der ist irgendwie Mitglied in der Glasgow Whiskey Society. Und was die machen, die gehen immer hin zu den Distillen und trinken sich so durch die Fässer durch. Und wenn ihnen was besonders gut schmeckt, dann machen die eine Abfüllung von dem einen Fass Single Cask, wie man das so schön nennt. Und dann werden die ganzen Flaschen quasi da in die Society geholt und die bekommen dann eine Nummer und eine Beschreibung, wie es schmeckt. Was aber nicht drauf steht, ist, aus welcher Distille es ist. Das heißt, wenn du dann da hingehst und da die Sachen probierst, dann kannst du halt irgendwas kaufen, was dir gut schmeckt, ohne zu wissen, wer dahinter steckt. Und bist also quasi von dem ganzen Placebo-Effekt des großen Namens einer Whiskey-Distille befreit. Und der hat eine von diesen Flaschen mitgebracht, die war unglaublich. Also sowas habe ich noch nicht getrunken. Also das ist so... Wow. Aber die anderen Sachen waren halt auch nicht schlecht. So ein 21-Jähriger, sonst was. Also das ist so... Und da konnten die Russen natürlich jetzt wiederum nicht so mithalten.
Hast du denn jetzt das einordentliche Wodka da getrunken, oder ja?
Ja, und zwar... Und zwar am... Hier ist nicht so ganz der letzte Abend.
Am Flughafen.
Nee, es war so, am letzten Abend waren wir erst länger in der Kneipe. Und dann sind die alle noch bei uns ins Hotel, in die Hotelbar. Aber die Hotelbar war irgendwie so in der Lobby mit drin, dass man, wenn man aus dem Hotel wieder rausgegangen ist oder irgendwie reinkam, sah man die Leute direkt an der Bar. Und da war ich halt irgendwie, musste relativ früh aufstehen fürs Flugzeug. Und hab halt kurz gepennt. Bin dann wieder aufgestanden, um dann irgendwie zum Flughafen zu fahren. War noch ein bisschen früh dran. Dann saßen die halt da noch. Irgendwie morgens um vier oder was es war. Und dann hatten sich da in der Zwischenzeit auch so eine Runde Russen eingefunden. Und die waren dann ganz fröhlich. Und hier und da und Leute und trinken. Ja, und dann gab es halt noch eine Runde Wodka. Und dann hab ich halt, bevor ich dann zum Flughafen gefahren bin, hab ich dann noch die Runde Wodka mitgenommen. Vier Stunden bis St. Petersburg und noch mal zwei oder zweieinhalb bis Berlin. Sechs Stunden Zeitunterschied.
Na, aber die haben sich wieder rausgelassen.
Ja, ich glaube, rauslassen ist nicht so schwierig wie reinkommen.
Ne, demnächst kannst du ja hier als Kriegsgefangener.
Naja, also sagen wir mal so, zum Visum zu kommen, ist ein bisschen aufwendig, weil es doch relativ viel Papierkram ist mit Einladung und dieses und jenes und dann wollen sie einen Verdienstnachweis, ob man denn auch zahlungskräftig genug ist, dass man wieder nach Hause fahren möchte und nicht dort bleibt, um dort sein Geld zu verdienen oder so. Aber das ist halt nur Verwaltungsakt, das ist eigentlich nicht schwierig. Eine spezielle Sache über iOS. Ich schmeiße jetzt einfach den Link mal rein, wenn ich das mal so auf die Schonelle finde.
Schmeiß doch mal den Link da rein.
Den Link da rein. Genau, Codefest.ru. Wo ist es denn? Programmer.
Wenn ich jetzt eine Ruhwebseite aufsuche, dann habe ich doch bestimmt...
Dann hast du mal so richtig... Dann hast du mal so richtig kyrillisch an der Backe. Also, ja, es ist nicht so schlimm. Kyrillisch geht schon so. So, hier. Da ist jetzt im Chat und dann wahrscheinlich auch in den Show-Notes direkt irgendwie...
Die Wahrheit.
Ah, da gibt es auch mal ein blödes Video. Da wollten die unbedingt ein Video von mir, wo ich dann sage...
Na, was sagst du? Darf ich?
Ja, ich glaube, es ist nicht so.
You know, Listening Tour oder was?
Hi, my name is Rued Gelsbeel and I'm from Berlin. I'm working at eBay. Ich dachte, das ist fürchterlich.
Na gut.
Und da gibt's noch meine Folien. Super.
Nicht schlecht.
Ach so, ja, gleich das erste Foto.
Hast du das nicht auch getwittert?
Ja, und zwar die Jungs von 2GIS, das sind die, die eigentlich auch die Konferenz machen, die hatten da so eine Fotoecke, wo sie diese so Kissen-Kuschelbuchstaben hatten, mit denen man irgendwie Wörter zusammenbauen konnte. Und irgendwie haben sie gesagt, ja, sollen doch hier die Namen ihrer Lieblingsprogrammiersprache usw. Und da gab es halt relativ viel so Java, PHP, was weiß ich, C-Sharps und Zeug. Und da dachte ich so, oh ja, jetzt muss sie die Buchstaben zusammen sammeln.
Hatten die auch einen Lattenzaun da als Buchstaben?
Jaja, die hatten auch zwei Plusse für was auch immer. Und da habe ich dann die Buchstaben für Objective-C zusammen gesammelt. Die wollten aber da nicht hängen bleiben, deswegen.
Musstest du sie irgendwie festhalten.
Natürlich.
Weißt du gar nicht, dass das so viel mit Objective-C zu tun hat?
Nee, hat es auch nicht.
Du hast sogar ein russisches Wort eingebracht.
Ja, das war in der Vorlage von der Präse drin.
Ach so, das kann man dann einfach benutzen, das Wort.
Die haben mir die Vorlage geschickt und dann habe ich das einfach so.
Was heißt das?
Fragen oder was?
Ich glaube ja.
Weißt du, wie man das ausspricht?
Voprossi oder so ähnlich.
Voprossi.
Oh, jetzt werde ich wahrscheinlich, jetzt kriege ich wahrscheinlich Ärger, weil ich es falsch ausgesprochen habe, aber ich kann halt auch kein Russisch. Ich kann so ein paar Buchstaben lesen, aber das war es dann auch schon.
Ja, ich habe auch mal für kurze Zeit versucht, irgendwie so kurdische Realität reinzuziehen, aber das war dann...
Ach, das geht, wenn man es ein paar Mal gemacht hat.
Ja klar, alles geht, wenn man es ein paar Mal gemacht hat, aber das muss man erst mal ein paar Mal machen. Ja, schön. So eine Reise, da kann man was erzählen. Und Microsoft sponsert sowas. Na ja, aber Microsoft, habe ich ja gehört, ist ja jetzt wieder cool.
JetBrains, das waren die...
Warte, Microsoft hat eine Objective-C... Nee, was war das für eine Konferenz?
Die hatten da Tracks für Backend, die hatten Tracks für QA, die hatten für Frontend, für Mobile, für hast du nicht gesehen. Und Microsoft hat da auch so ein paar Workshops zum Thema, ja zu ihren Themen angeboten, weiß ich nicht.
Kommen wir dann...
Was ist abspielen den Sound jetzt hier?
Themenmäßig überleitend zur WWDC rüberdenksen, um das Informationsschnipsel kurz einzustreuen.
Ja, hat jemand eine Karte bekommen?
Hat jemand eine Karte bestellt?
Ich habe eine bestellt, obwohl ich wusste, dass ich nicht hin kann, aber ich dachte, schaust du doch mal.
Ich verstehe, Lotterie spielen nur zum Glücklichwerden und jetzt bist du unglücklich. Das ist natürlich ziemlich doof, ne, Roddy?
Nee, also ich sag mal so, wenn du Lotterie spielst und weißt, dass die Niete sowieso besser passt, weil du sonst nur Ärger hast.
Stell dir vor, du hättest willkommen.
Ich glaube, dann hätten mich meine Kollegen allesamt gehauen, weil die nämlich alle hinwollten und alle keine Karten gekriegt haben. Also ich kenne keinen Menschen, der eigentlich...
Achso, ist das schon durch?
Ja, das ist schon durch.
Das Los ist gezogen.
Das ging ja relativ schnell wieder mal.
Ich habe noch von niemandem irgendwas gehört, dass er eine Karte bekommen hat.
Ich glaube Toto und so, also Next Big Thing haben, glaube ich, eine.
Haben die nicht als Mitarbeiter weniger, habe ich gehört?
Nehme ich.
Schon länger.
Den Max? Ist bei Facebook, höre ich. Hier im Chat.
Was?
Ja.
In Amiland.
Sicher.
Sagen die alle?
Das hat er zumindest, weil wir müssen reden, behauptet.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, ich glaube Toto hat gemeint, sie hätten eine Karte. Zumindest wollen sie Berichterstattung machen von der WDWC und den...
Ja, aber eigentlich seitdem die so super mit Videos jetzt abgedeckt ist, was will man mehr?
Muss den Arsch nicht hochziehen.
Direkt zu Griff auf die Programmierer haben, die alle die ganzen Bugs verkackt haben, die nicht ordentlich dokumentiert sind, damit du sie auf dem Weg zum Klo am Schlawittchen packen kannst und sagen kannst, wie heißt das Bit, was ich setzen muss, damit meine Scheiße läuft.
Ja, das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht die Herangehensweise, die zielführend ist, aber im Großen und Ganzen will man die Leute rankriegen.
Wo ist der Go-to-Fail-Typ?
Der sitzt da und schreibt Autogramme. Dann hole ich mir aber lieber eins von diesem See, wie ist er?
Segemann.
Segemann See.
2G.
Habe übrigens noch einen Link zum SSL vergessen, den ich auch dem Chat und den Hörern zu Gemüte führen wollte, nämlich diesen da. Wohl Paul Henningkamp, der Warnisch geschrieben hat oder auch am FreeBSD verleisig gearbeitet hat, schon 2011 eine Seite kurz einen Text geschrieben hat, warum er kein SSL in sein Warnisch einbauen will. Ein sehr performanter noch dazu. Ja, der Second ist auch gut. Da drunter ein paar Zeilen drunter.
340.722 lines of code.
340.000 Zeilen, muss man sich mal reinziehen.
Was für SSL?
Krasse Scheiße.
Was?
Was machen die da?
Ja genau, das fragen sich auch alle.
Wir waren jetzt hier bei Second. It's not exactly the best source code in the world. Und dann hat er hier so einen Code-by-commentar, das alleine schon irgendwie. Also wenn das eine Stelle ist, die er sich da gerade mal rausgegriffen hat, dann wird das wahrscheinlich auch nicht die Letzte gewesen sein. Here be dragons.
Das Internet ist einfach ein löchriger Topf.
You get what you pay for.
Das Kommerzielle ist halt auch kaputt, da kann keiner reingucken. Man kann es so finden, aber es wird dann halt bei Accident gefunden.
Ob die Erlang-Implementierung irgendwie toller ist?
Die benutzen jetzt auch, machen jetzt Ereignisse. Ich glaube, die machen ihre Ereignisse jetzt.
Aber es ist auch eigentlich grundsätzlich so, umso größer irgendwie Zeug wird, umso weniger blicken die Leute durch und umso mehr Fehler macht man, oder? Ist einfach so. Der Mensch hat nun mal begrenzten Überblick und bei 340.000 Zeilen mal ehrlich. So viel Abstraction können die gar nicht da drin haben, um das alles auseinanderzuhalten. Und wenn ich das richtig sehe, wird das in einen OpenSSL reingebaut, oder was?
Aber Oracle schafft es ja auch, ne? So eine Oracle-Datenbank, die hat doch mehr Source Code als irgendwie ein Betriebssystem, glaube ich.
Die hat wahrscheinlich auch mehr Sicherheitslücken als so ein Betriebssystem.
Aber die behalten ja scheinbar den Überblick, ja?
Tja, muss eigentlich alles neu geschrieben werden.
Gibt es irgendwie im Internet zu lesen, wie viele Zeilen auf Code das Oracle Database Core-Ding hat? Das würde mich mal interessieren.
Ja, dafür möchte ich mal so eine schöne Infographics sehen. Lines of Codes von diversen Projekten. Gut, haben wir das Konferenz-Ding? Fertig, haben wir durch.
Muss auch mal wieder auf eine Konferenz gehen.
Also ich bin jetzt erstmal durch, vor allen Dingen mit Fliegen und Flughafen und so weiter. Da habe ich jetzt keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Ja, irgendwann ist es dann auch gut, ne? Ich finde es trotzdem immer sehr bereichernd, solche kulturellen Ausflüge vorzunehmen. Und wenn es auch nur mal so ein Wochenende, drei Tage ist, reicht völlig aus. Man bleibt auch immer so enorm in Erinnerung.
Auf jeden Fall.
Also das finde ich auch echt so bemerkenswert. Ich war auch mal so ein paar Tage in Kuala Lumpur auf einer Konferenz. Wieso ohje?
Das ist weit weg.
Ja, das ist weit weg, klar. Fliegt man hin, dann ist man da. Eigentlich ist es nur der Jetlag, aber das ist halt nun mal...
Ja, der hat mich auch erwischt.
Ja, kein Wunder.
Hin mehr als zurück.
Ja, aber dann ist es einfach, ich finde es irgendwie auch so geil, so ganz weit weg zu sein. Und dann auf der einen Seite siehst du halt, was alles so unglaublich anders ist, als die eigene tägliche Realität. Also du siehst natürlich sofort all die Dinge, die komplett andere Ansätze haben. Also alles natürlich, was schon so mit Essen, Traditionen, Religion, den ganzen Klimbim, wie man miteinander umgeht und so weiter. Je nach Land klafft es ja dann doch extrem auseinander. Aber auf dem gleichen Moment, obwohl die Herangehensweisen eigentlich alle sehr unterschiedlich sein können, merkst du dann, dass sie am Ende des Tages aber auch dieselben Dinge tun?
Ja, es ist sehr gut dann über die...
Die leben da, die atmen irgendwie, küssen sich und...
Ja, es hinterfragt sehr viele Dinge, die einem normal erscheinen. Wenn man plötzlich merkt, dass jemand anderes das anders tut, dann fängt man darüber an, nachzudenken, warum machen die das anders? Und dann denkt man letzten Endes wieder darüber nach, warum mache ich das eigentlich so, wie ich das tue und warum ist das normal für mich? Und dann kriegt man einen ganz anderen Zugang auch zu dem, was man zu Hause hat. Finde ich, ehrlich gesagt, auch immer wieder sehr, sehr gut. Und dann im zweiten Schritt merkt man dann, eigentlich so toll ist es ja eigentlich auch nicht, was wir hier machen. Und vielleicht haben die ja gar nicht so Unrecht bei dem, was sie da tun.
Naja, wobei man natürlich so als Deutscher auch im Ausland immer so ein bisschen dieses Baustellenproblem hat.
Das Baustellenproblem?
Ja, kennst du das nicht?
Also in Berlin kenne ich das Baustellenproblem.
Was ist denn das Baustellenproblem?
Ja, mir fallen halt andere Länder vor allem immer an ihren Baustellen auf. Und wenn man so mit einer deutschen Attitüde da rangeht, dann denkt man sich immer gleich so, ah, das könnte man doch auch anders machen.
Ich sag mal so, in Nowosibirsk habe ich keine Baustellen gesehen.
Ach so, da wird gar nichts gebaut.
Aber es wäre vielleicht ganz gut gewesen, wenn sie die eine oder andere gehabt hätten.
Ja, aber es gibt abenteuerliche Konstruktionen und so. Weißt du, je nach Land auch so Holzlatten-Konstruktionen, wo du bei uns kein Holz sehen würdest und so weiter.
Apropos Holzlatten, Oracle Database hat ca. 70 Millionen Holzlatten.
Holzlatten auf Code?
70 Millionen Lines of Code. Alles mit Trello gemanagt. Oh Gott, 70 Millionen Lines of Code.
So, was ist denn das hier für ein Link? Ach so, da steht das mit den 70 Millionen Lines of Code.
Die lateinischen Namen sind sehr schön.
Kannst du mal suchen nach 70, dann findest du es da relativ schnell nach dem zweiten. Ich hab noch mal, ja, da war's schon.
Multi Crepico, der Malvaro-Müsterin. 70 Millionen Lines of Code. Die haben da bestimmt irgendwie noch zwei oder drei Betriebssysteme drin versteckt.
Es gibt wohl Leute, die meinen, dass Datenbanken mussweilen tatsächlich komplexer sind als Betriebssysteme. Und es gibt ja auch Features aus Datenbanken, die später dann in die USA gekommen sind. Also ZFS zum Beispiel hat ja auf jeden Fall einige Inspirationen aus der Datenbankwelt übernommen.
So, für die Freunde der Apple News, eine haben wir.
Welche denn?
Die WDC war schon vorbei.
Ja, es gibt so ein Gerücht, die Quelle müsst ihr selber suchen, so ist es halt bei Gerüchten, dass Apple vorhat, das Baseband, ich hab das von Max Schärfer, falls du es suchst, dass Apple das Baseband selber bauen will, also bisher ist es ja so, dass die von Qualcomm, die haben ja auch Leute eingestellt, früher auch von Broadcom, also die wechseln ja auch immer, weil sie selber wechseln, weil sie gegeneinander ausspielen, so wie AMD und Nvidia Standard-Business. Jedenfalls wollen sie die Dollars irgendwie ganz einsparen oder noch mehr einsparen zumindest und wollen ein Baseband selber machen. So richtig viel mehr Informationen gibt es da nicht. Aber meine Erweiterung von diesem Gerücht ist natürlich, dass der Timme sich da voll freuen wird, weil natürlich, denke ich mal, sind diese schlau und werden nicht ein selbstgemachtes Baseband mal so ins nächste Telefon schmeißen, das ist viel zu risky, sondern die werden das machen, um hier das nächste MacBook Air, MacBook irgendwas mit GSM, also Netz zu versorgen, mobile. Und wenn das gut läuft, dann werden sie es irgendwann dann auch ins Telefon reinschmeißen. Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, nächstes Jahr Baseband...
Warte mal, die Logik habe ich jetzt nicht nachvollzogen. Du meinst die Tatsache, dass Apple eine eigene Baseband-Software macht, oder Hardware macht. Hardware-Software macht. Sprich dafür, dass sie das in einen Mac einbauen? Wo ist da jetzt der logische Schluss?
Na, weil du den ersten Beta-Tralala willst du nicht gleich in deren Big Business Telefon machen. Wenn sie das verkacken, dann ist vorbei. Dann kauft dir ja keiner mehr.
Also, an der Argumentation ist natürlich was dran.
Ja, aber das würde für die Mac-Plattform genauso schlecht aussehen.
Aber das ist nicht so schlimm, dann telefoniere ich nicht mit. Das geht dann halt mal nicht. Das ist noch nicht so mega wichtig. Und es kaufen nicht gleich Millionen von Leuten einen neuen Mac und so weiter. Beim Telefon, das kaufen gleich, da weiß ich nicht, wie viele Millionen, das ist einfach mal der Fail, wäre da um...
Sagt ja keiner, dass sie wirklich bei Null anfangen.
Vielleicht machen sie es erst ins iPad.
Ich behaupte, das kommt erst hier in den...
Also was würde denn dafür sprechen für dieses Gerücht? Also erstmal, Apple mag es nicht.
Also was ist am Ende mal deren Entscheidung?
Ja gut, erstmal heißt es ja, eine Menge Geld in die Hand nehmen, weil du musst ja das developen, aber davor haben sie halt keine Angst. Andererseits bedeutet das, sie haben dann mal wieder eine Technologie in der Hand, weil sie, wenn sie irgendwas nicht mögen, dann, dass Subsysteme von anderen Leuten poämiert werden, mit Bugs.
Ja, was ist denn noch im Telefon, der größte Teil in einem iPhone jetzt, der ihnen nicht gehört ist, ist wahrscheinlich der Baseband-Chip. Alles andere ist doch schon ersetzt, oder Klingelminigramen, der nicht interessiert ist, wahrscheinlich der Vibrator oder so. Aber sonst ist doch alles schon übernommen.
Okay, aber sie müssen mit dem Teil ohnehin durch so eine Abnahmeprozedur anpassen.
FCC meint sie.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wer das dann konkret macht, aber halt so die üblichen, verdächtigen GSM. Du darfst hier auch funken. Wenn sie das bestehen...
Na, die fangen bestimmt nicht komplett bei Null an. Aber ich glaube trotzdem, das ist nicht sofort ihr ersten Chip, den sie da bauen, ins Fonds meiten.
Okay, das lasse ich jetzt mal offen. Ehrlich gesagt, ich rechne fest damit, dass sie das in das iPhone einbauen.
Ja, aber nicht sofort. Du meinst gleich sofort.
Es kann schon sein, dass sie versuchen, erst mal weniger Risiko zu fahren und das Ding, weiß ich nicht, ins Apple TV einbauen.
Ja, aber nur weil sie Angst haben, das in ihr Telefon einzubauen, dann auf einmal zu entscheiden, ah ja, dann können wir ja das auch mal in die Macs einbauen.
Oder nur in Teil der Telefone.
Wenn sie der Meinung waren, dass sie das in dem Mac drin haben, dann hätten sie das schon längst drin seit Jahren.
Die Argumentation würde ich auch unterschreiben. Also nur das in Mac zu tun, weil sie jetzt einen eigenen GSM-Baseband-Chip haben, den sie testen müssen, ist jetzt irgendwie eine schwache Argumentation. Aber die andere Argumentation, das ist vielleicht jetzt nicht gleich einbaut bei dem Produkt mit dem höchsten Umsatz. Da ist wahrscheinlich was dran. Keine Ahnung, wenn sie das iPhone 5C noch mal redesignen als iPhone 5D oder keine Ahnung, wie das dann heißt.
Sie wollen ja keinen Baseband-Gate bei ihrem Flexiproduct.
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie die da bei Apple, auf welcher Basis die aufbauen. Aber wenn ich da Manager wäre und wir fangen wirklich von vorn an, dann würde ich sagen, ich habe da nicht so gutes Gefühl, lasst mal langsam anfangen.
Auf der anderen Seite kann ich mir vorstellen, dass es dann drei Jahre dauert, bis die dann zu einem Punkt kommen, wo sie sagen, okay, das können wir jetzt so verwenden.
Also langsam anfangen heißt für die dann einfach, sie bauen es erstmal nur in ihre Testgeräte ein und dann vielleicht irgendwie jedes zehnte Ei. Aber ich kaufe dir die Argumentation nicht ab. Das würde mich sehr wundern. Erstens, Baseband-Chip und die Software usw. Ich meine, das ist einfach beherrschbare Technologie.
Aber was ich mir vorschränke...
Das ist nicht der totale Voodoo. Und vor allem, es gibt noch einen anderen großen Grund, warum sie unbedingt ihr Telefon reinhaben wollen. Weil dieser Baseband-Kram natürlich auch ein Security-Vector ist und ein ganz wichtiger.
Was sie natürlich machen könnten, was mir glaubwürdig erscheint, ist, dass sie diesen Baseband-Kram mit in den Prozessor tun. Die bauen ja jetzt schon ihre eigenen Prozessoren, wo jede Menge Rümpel drin ist, die die anderen nicht reinbauen. Und wenn sie in der Lage sind, jetzt den ganzen Baseband-Scheiß auch noch mit aufs gleiche Die zu packen...
Mit auf denselben SoC drauf, ja.
Dann kriegen sie mal so richtig Platz gespart. Und Strom. Dann passt das auch in eine Uhr ans Handgelenk, oder in eine Brille, oder you name it. Das ist ein sehr gutes Argument. Das könnte ich mir vorstellen. Aber einfach nur einen eigenen Chip bauen, wäre jetzt ein bisschen cool.
Vielleicht haben sie auch einfach nur das Design gekauft, um es in ihren SoC mit reinzuklatschen. Da müssen sie gar nicht alles neu machen.
Eben. Es geht nur darum, dass sie quasi ein Design kaufen, was sie dann implementieren können, so wie sie es mit den Prozessoren auch gemacht haben.
Das ist jetzt die Frage. Wo sind sie jetzt mit ihrem Arm? Bei 22 Nanometer raus? Oder sind die in der 14-Macht-Intel jetzt? Die sind noch bei 22. Ich glaube, 20 ist das nächste, was sie anstünden. Es ist die Frage, ob der Baseband-Chip in dem iPhone bei wie vielen Nanometern der ist. Der ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht ganz so klein, aber es ist halt noch eine teure Sache. Da können die auch noch mal ein bisschen Gewinn durchmachen, wenn die Strukturen genauso klein sind wie bei dem Arm.
Vor allem, was ich mich frage, so ein Baseband-Chip ist doch im Prinzip auch nur ein Arm-Chip. Da ist ja auch ein Arm drin und da läuft auch irgendein Code drauf, der jede Menge DSP macht. Die Frage ist, kann man nicht den ganzen Scheiß mit vom Hauptprozessor...
Früher hieß sowas Softmodem. Vielleicht ist es jetzt wieder so weit.
Ist sowieso alles schon irgendwie soft. Also, wie Roddi schon sagt, es ist nur die Frage, ob du das quasi voll integrieren kannst und auch dein ganzes Power-Management besser mitrealisieren kannst. Und natürlich dann eben dir auch noch mal einen Stein sparst.
Das würde schon Sinn machen, weil das iPhone 5S hat jetzt schon so viel Power, das brauchst du eh nie. Und...
Da gibt es bestimmt eine Uhr. Na ja, wenn sie es so klein machen, dann bauen sie eine Uhr.
Ach so, du meinst hier so ein wearable eyewatch-Sack?
Max hat es vorausgesagt.
Max wollte eine Küchenuhr haben oder sowas.
Nee, nee, der wollte schon eine Armbanduhr haben.
Ja, guck mal, ist auf jeden Fall spannend. Also ich finde das Gerücht, ob es Grundlagen hat oder nicht, keine Ahnung, aber es ist interessant zu sehen, was da in der Richtung noch passieren könnte.
Ich finde es auf jeden Fall cool, dass sie irgendwie immer noch so dieses, wir bauen alles Ding, irgendwie so gnadenlos durchziehen.
Weil man ein Fallsystem bauen.
Ja, genau, die Fallsystem.
Das ist ja das Problem mit meinen Ears.
Das ist ja Ears, genau.
Das kann manchmal auch nicht so hilfreich sein.
Gut, wenn wir jetzt schon gerade bei Armband waren, gibt es noch die nächste kurze News, die man erwähnen kann. Ich glaube, es stand auch Heise. Wahrscheinlich hat es eh jeder gelesen, der heute uns hier zuhört. Aber da stand da, dass es jetzt von ARM, die haben einen neuen Compiler draußen, und bisher war das wohl immer was Eigenes. Die haben jetzt in der neuesten Version auch auf LLVM umgeschwenkt und benutzen jetzt die komplette LLVM-Infrastruktur. Das ist nur eine kleine News, aber das...
wird einfach in zunehmendem Maße der Standard.
Ja, sieht so aus. Und vor allem ist es ja auch für LLVM weiterhin gut, wenn da erstens, also ARM gab es ja schon den Support in LLVM, aber wenn halt für verschiedene Architekturen die Zeugkoden, für LLVM ist das immer gut. Und wenn da noch mehr Leute mitmachen, wird es ja immer stabiler, besser, schneller usw.
Ja, und vor allem die Erfinder von diesem ganzen Kram, das selber benutzen, dann ist das gut.
Welche Erfinder?
Wir reden doch jetzt wirklich von ARM, die Firma ARM.
Genau, die denen halt Compiler für ihre ARM-Chips rausgeben. So wie halt Intel für ihr seine Intel-CPUs usw. Und die armen Leute machen jetzt halt LLVM.
Naja, sagen wir mal so, wenn halt irgendwie seit 20 Jahren niemand mehr einen Compiler von Grund auf neu gebaut hat, weil sie alle gesagt haben, GCC ist gut genug.
Ja, so würde ich das auch nicht sehen. Ich weiß ja nicht, wie lange es die anderen Compiler schon gibt. Also IBM hat ja einen hier bei CodeWarrior war einer, Motorola hatte eine eigene Intel, hatte einen eigenen, also die und Sun hatte auch ein bisschen. Aber Compiler schon gar nicht so wenig.
Ja, ja, schon klar, die waren sicherlich auch alle gut, aber hier mal die ganze Sache einfach nochmal neu zu machen mit all den Erfahrungen, die man gemacht hat mit einem Compiler, der inzwischen so in der Sackgasse des Refactorings angelangt ist, das Nötigen, das ist schon sinnvoll.
Neumachen ist immer gut, sieht man ja bei Subversion. Ach nee, die wurden dann von Git überholt. Musst jetzt mal raus.
Och, Subversion hatte so seine paar Jahre an der Sonne, auf jeden Fall.
Ein oder zwei.
Na, Git ist ja wiederum das Beispiel.
Ja, die hat es wirklich unglücklich erwischt.
Ja, mein Geschmack kann noch häufiger mal was komplett neu gemacht werden. Würde mir so einiges einfallen. Ja, iOS 8 zum Beispiel können Sie auch schön komplett neu machen. Kriegen wir das denn jetzt eigentlich auf dieser...
Auf der WWDC?
Na, ersten Ausblick bestimmt. Wann ist die WWDC?
Also eigentlich stellen Sie neue Betriebssysteme immer auf der WWDC vor. Ob wir jetzt ein neues Mavericks Nachfolger kriegen oder einen neuen iOS Nachfolger, weiß man natürlich nicht. Aber da Sie jetzt iOS eigentlich immer im Jahresabstand eine neue große Version rausgebracht haben, kann man glaube ich schwer davon ausgehen, dass wir ein iOS 8 sehen werden, was auch immer dann da drin ist. Vielleicht ist ja nur ein bisschen an der Oberfläche gekratzt.
Sie beeilen sich so, damit sie bald iOS X rausbringen können.
Sie müssen einfach das GUI überarbeiten.
Whatever, was auch immer Sie da überarbeiten müssen. Aber auf jeden Fall denke ich, werden wir ein iOS 8 sehen.
Blaskugeln werden auch ein bisschen.
Ich kann nur sagen, was ich haben wollen würde.
Ja, natürlich, klar. Ich meine, wir wissen eh nicht, was kommt.
Also gut, das ist eigentlich die Sache, über die ich dann doch diese Woche nicht mehr reden wollte, weil ich mich nicht genug eingearbeitet habe. Aber eigentlich will ich Reactive Coco sehen, als festen Bestandteil von Coco. Also Reactive Coco ist, jetzt muss ich ein bisschen schwimmen. Jetzt muss ich doch ein bisschen schwimmen. Im Großen und Ganzen ist es so, du baust dein User-Interface zusammen so ein bisschen wie eine Audio-Engine. Also wenn irgendwo was passiert, ein Event reinkommt, dann nennt man das ein Signal. Und du kannst ein Signal durch ein Modul durchschicken und dann kommt hinten wieder was raus. Das Beispiel, was sie gerne bringen ist, du hast ein Eingabefeld für Username und Passwort. Und aus dem Username-Feld kommt ein Signal raus. Immer wenn da eine Buchstabe neu dazu kommt, dann ist dieses Signal, jetzt ist der String wieder länger geworden. Und aus dem Eingabefeld kommt ein Signal, wie jetzt ist der String wieder länger geworden. Und diese beiden Signale fütterst du in ein Modul, was sagt, der Username hat eine bestimmte Qualität und das Passwort hat eine bestimmte Qualität. Und wenn das alles erfüllt ist, dann kommt hinten als Bullion dann so das Signal raus, jetzt bitte den OK-Button enablen oder lieber noch disablet lassen. Das ist so der grobe Ding, wie sie sich das vorstellen.
Und dafür machen die so einen riesigen Alarm. Ich meine, da lohnt sich das. Da steckt bestimmt noch mehr dahinter.
Das Interessante daran ist, dass dieses, was ich jetzt als Modul bezeichnet habe, eigentlich so gebaut wird, wie man funktionale Programmierung macht. Also das Modul an sich hat keinen State. Sondern es ist nur eine Funktion, wo du eine Eingabe hast und eine Ausgabe. Und die Ausgabe hängt nur an der Eingabe, weil das Modul selber keinen State hat.
Schön parallelisierbar, weniger Seiteneffekte.
Richtig, genau. Und das ist eigentlich so das, was dahinter steckt. Ich habe es mir leider noch nicht genug angeguckt und ich habe es mir auch, ich will das wenn möglich irgendwann mal benutzen. Aber der Grundgedanke ist, du kannst Signale kombinieren und in Modulen die Signale kombinieren und filtern und tun und machen und immer kommt hinten was raus. Und das Schöne daran ist, dass du diesen ganzen State, den du normalerweise brauchst, weg abstrahieren kannst. Weil normalerweise brauchst du, du musst irgendwie, du musst dein Textfeld irgendwo andrahten, da ist jetzt die Funktion, dass das Textfeld sich geändert hat. Dann musst du das Textfeld abfragen, ach du hast dich geändert, was ist denn jetzt dein String? Und wenn du dann den String abgefragt hast, dann kannst du woanders, da ist der Button und dann kann ich dem Button sagen jetzt sei mal Enabled oder Disabled und du musst die Strings zwischen speichern und tun und machen. Und das ist jetzt ein einfaches Beispiel und an dem einfachen Beispiel ist es auch noch nicht so offensichtlich, was jetzt der Vorteil daran ist. Aber eigentlich ist der Vorteil daran, dass du halt diese Module sind halt stateless. Und du kannst halt relativ viele hintereinander schalten, auch so Sachen wie, ich mache einen Netzwerk-Call, aus dem Netzwerk-Call kommen hinten Daten raus. Wenn dieser Netzwerk-Call ein Modul ist, dann kann ich als Ergebnis des Netzwerk-Calls sagen, da hänge ich den nächsten Netzwerk-Call auch als Modul ran. Und sobald aus dem ersten Netzwerk-Call Daten kommen, wird der zweite Netzwerk-Call getriggert, ohne dass diese beiden Module selber groß state halten. Normalerweise ist das ein großer Pain, diese, ich mache drei Netzwerk-Calls hintereinander, die voneinander abhängen, das ist immer sehr unschön. Und da ist Netz wirklich nett gelöst. Und das hätte ich gerne in iOS 8, von Apple in gut, mit scharfe Soße.
Aber du hast jetzt keinen besonderen Anlass zu glauben, dass das jetzt auch kommt, nur so hättest du gern.
Ich habe keinen besonderen Anlass zu glauben, dass es kommt, nein. Der einzige Anlass ist, was so subsummiert wird, unter Massive View Controller, also das Programmierparadigma von Coco heißt ja MVC, Model View Controller. Und irgendjemand hat dann mal getweetet, wofür steht eigentlich MVC, Massive View Controller. Das Problem ist nämlich, dass der View Controller, so wie er benutzt wird in Coco, eigentlich extrem viele Verantwortung an sich zieht und dadurch extrem groß wird. Und diese ganzen Verantwortlichkeiten extrem, also es ist schon schwierig, die auseinander zu dividieren und auseinander zu halten. Sowas wie, wenn ich zum nächsten Screen navigiere, wie navigiere ich da? Wenn ich eine Table View habe? Wo kommt die Daten her? Wie werden die Daten an die Table View weitergeleitet? Und diesen ganzen Kram, das führt dazu, dass man eben massive View Controller hat, weil die alle relativ groß ist. Also 1000 Lines of Code für einen View Controller ist fast noch klein. Gerne mal. Je nachdem, wie man das so macht. Und das ist ein Problem, das muss Apple in den Griff kriegen. Dieses massive View Controller Problem. Und meiner Meinung nach, ob es jetzt Reactive Cocoa ist, oder weiß ich nicht, was für eine Lösung, aber sie müssen da was bringen. Und meine Hoffnung ist, dass sie wenigstens teilweise das in iOS 8 mal angehen. Ja, jetzt habe ich so lange geredet.
Das ist ja in Ordnung. Tim spielt Pong und ich spiele Pong. Ich habe mir jetzt gerade mal nebenbei hier so die Ressourcen zu dem Begriff angeklickt und bin bei einer Sprache gelandet.
Die Elm heißt sie.
Die Elm heißt sie. Hast du von der schon mal was gehört?
Nein, habe ich aber auch gelesen, als ich mich über dieses Reactive Functional Programming informiert habe.
Sie sagt von sich, dass sie im Wesentlichen genau dieses Konzept, das du jetzt so ausführlich dargestellt hast, implementiert. Und zwar ist sie so gemacht, dass du sie zu HTML, JavaScript und CSS kompilierst. Das heißt, du kannst damit mal so eben so ein Webgame oder eine Web abbauen, wie zum Beispiel so ein kleines Pong, das ich hier gerade versuche, gerade mit mir selber zu spielen. Und das ist natürlich auch ein schönes Beispiel insofern, als dass du hier halt wirklich mit vielen Events auch zu tun hast und natürlich möglichst effizient sein willst. Man will das mit jeder Poemie-Sprache, aber man kriegt das nicht unbedingt mit jeder hin. Da müsste man sich mal diesen Sourcecode anschauen hier von dem Pong und bewerten, ob das viel ist, aber das kommt mir jetzt nicht viel vor für so ein Spiel, muss ich sagen. Also normalerweise ist hier so eine anderthalb Bildschirmseite voll. Das hast du normalerweise schon an CSS. Auch für den Game, wenn du es überhaupt so machst.
Ja gut, du weißt ja jetzt nicht, in wieviel CSS das kompiliert. Nee, aber ich muss es ja nicht schreiben.
Normalerweise müsste ich das ja alles selber schreiben. Und von daher finde ich das schon mal sehr interessant.
Aber der Code ist auch dichter, muss man mal sagen, fairerweise. So ein CSS ist ja wie gewöhnlich. Ja, flufig, in der Horizontal.
Also das würdest du sicherlich in JavaScript hier auch...
Stimmt, bis zur zehnten Spalte und dann ist meistens schon Feierabend. Ja gut, da hängt noch ein bisschen was dran. Ja klar, logisch.
Aber es sieht auf jeden Fall jetzt auf den ersten Schritt nicht ganz falsch aus. Und du hast halt hier auch vor allem diese... das hier so richtig deute, genau diesen Fluss hier irgendwie auch drin, kann das sein? Hier mit vielen Pfeilen und so. Naja, unsere gerechte Striche. Schon etwas skurrile Syntax hier. Schon fast grafisch aus. Und das ist nur der Editor? Ja. Das wünschst du dir.
Das wünsche ich mir.
Was wünschst du dir denn, Dennis?
Mehr User-Control, weniger Vault-Garden und besseren Datenaustausch zwischen iPhone und Desktop.
Ja, das unterschreibe ich.
AirDrop und AirDrop könnten sie mal kompatibel machen.
Ja, das ist eher eine Anforderung an OS X als an iOS.
Ja, beide Richtungen. Ist mir egal, auf welcher Seite das fixen.
Haben wir doch letztes Mal schon diskutiert, dass das im Wesentlichen jetzt an diesem neuen Treppel hängt.
Das können auch gerne noch eine neue...
Da haben wir ja nur gemutmaßt, wissen wir nicht, ob das so stimmt.
Hast du dieses AirDrop schon mal benutzt? AirDrop, meinste.
Na, mir selber vor allem will ich ab und zu was schicken. Ich will zum Beispiel ein Bild, was ich mit meinem Phone mache, schnell mal auf meinem Laptop haben. Was ist es? Ich muss mir das per Mail schicken. Und kommt ja nicht wieder mit eurem scheiß iCloud. Könnt ihr gleich vergessen.
Ich glaube aber, es wird einfach scheiße bleiben.
Du hast gesagt, was ich mir wünsche, nicht was ich denke, was kommt. Ne, aber so Austauschen von Daten, das muss einfach besser gehen. Und jetzt gab es ja hier von Steve diese Mail, weil die durch diesen Samsung-Prozess da ist. Und da stand ja da irgendwie hier... Erstens das und zweitens, dass alles geht über die Cloud. Also du hast keine Kontrolle mehr, wie du deine Daten tauschst. Alles geht über die. Das ist nicht mein Ding. Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Wenn es mal wenigstens ordentlich gehen würde.
Nein, auch dann nicht.
Aber wo ist denn die Cloud, wenn ich mal eben einen Film auf meinem Telefon haben will?
Ja, genau.
Wo tust du es denn hin?
Schiebst du ein paar Gigabyte in die Cloud und sie dann von da wieder runterzuladen.
Ja, das geht ja noch nicht mal.
Ja, vor allem wird es Stunden dauern.
Na, abgesehen davon, dass es vielleicht lange dauert. Damit könnte ich ja noch leben, dass es dauert. Aber wie? Es geht ja nicht. Du kannst nicht eine Datei auf dein Scheiß Telefon schieben.
Ja, und runter auch nicht.
Das ist einfach Dreck. Ich muss auch sagen, mein Excitement-Level bei Apple ist mittlerweile schon wirklich sehr niedrig. Mittlerweile habe ich schon gar keine Erwartungen mehr. Also ich glaube einfach gerade nicht mehr daran, dass sich dann auch irgendwas bessert. Der Trend geht wirklich in eine Richtung, die mir überhaupt nicht mehr gefällt. Und das finde ich scheiße.
Ich kriege auch jedes Mal einen Anfall, wenn mein Preview hier auf dem Mac öffnet und dann irgendwie Dokumentenkopie immer noch und jetzt ist es in die Cloud oder das Textedit und so und dieser ganze Scheiß.
Also das ist ja alles ganz schön für Leute, die da irgendwie draufstehen. Aber ich hätte gerne auch die Option, dass es halt nicht über um die Cloud geht. Oder, war ja schon mehrmals mein Vorschlag seit Jahren, auch auf Freak Show, Mobile Macs, die auch immer, ich will meine eigene Cloud. Dann können wir darüber reden, dann ist wieder alles schick. Aber eure Cloud könnt ihr voll vergessen. Kaufe ich mir einen Mac Pro, mache da irgendwie meine Cloud, zahl auch Euros dafür, ist mir alles egal, aber eure Cloud ist nicht. Und vor allem, ich meine, dafür, dass ich ein Bild von meinem Telefon zu dem circa jetzt gerade im Abstand von zwei Zentimeter danebenstehenden MacBook Pro rüberschiebe, muss ich deren Cloud benutzen, wo ich fünf Gigabyte hab und für noch mehr irgendwie Geld bezahlen muss. Ist ja auch nicht umsonst, also im Anfang vielleicht schon, aber wenn jedes Scheißprogramm, und das wollen ja gerne da seinen temporären Shit ablegt und so wird's enden, weil Programmierer sind alle faul, die werden natürlich alles Cloud-mäßig machen, dann sind die fünf Gigabyte ganz schnell voll, weil denen ist ja egal, dass ich da bezahlen muss und dann ist am Arsch. Das ist ja genau der gleiche Scheiß wie hier Heizkostenzählerdingens da, der Vermieter muss ja nicht bezahlen, sondern nur der Mieter. Also machen sie schönen Scheiß dahin. Wie heißt diese Firma? Ich vergess es immer.
Ja, gibt's mehrere, aber die sind alle scheiße.
Mal Luft abgelassen.
Ja, ich kann mir nicht so recht vorstellen, dass zum Thema Cloud so richtig viel passiert. Also vielleicht öffnen sie es, aber so richtig vorstellen kann ich es nicht.
Ja, nee, glaube ich nicht. Für die ist es natürlich schon ein Business. Die wollen halt die Leute da haben, weil da verdient man Geld. Jedes Jahr zahlen, immer wieder. Du kriegst ja Daten ja auch nicht wirklich darunter, wenn du die Programme weiter nutzen willst. Das ist doch jahrelanges Einkommen.
Was ich mir vorstellen kann, ist, dass bei Apple langsam die Vorstellung angekommen ist, dass das mit den Spielen doch eine ganz gute Idee ist und dass sich da Geld mit verdienen lässt. Und sie haben ja zur iOS 7 auch schon diese Controller-Dinger da eingeführt. Inzwischen kann man da auch einen ganzen Sack voll kaufen. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass in die Richtung auch noch ein bisschen mehr passiert. Was das dann sein wird, wird man sehen. Aber ich denke, das ist inzwischen angekommen, dass das einträglich ist, was mit Spielen zu machen. Ob das jetzt irgendwie dein Apple TV mit A7-Chip, wo man dann ordentliche Spiele drauf machen kann, ist, oder weiß ich nicht. Aber da kann ich mir was vorstellen. Und vielleicht passiert auch noch mal was zu CarPlay, CarPlay für die Allgemeinheit. Dass man da jetzt dann doch auch als normalsterblicher Entwickler irgendwie was drauf darstellen darf. Und nicht nur, wenn man irgendwie eingeweiter ist im inneren Circle. Das kann auch noch sein. Ja, ich weiß, das sind alles so Themen, die jetzt nicht so rocken. Die es nicht so rocken, aber...
Ja, man darf vielleicht mitspielen. Also drehen wir es nochmal andersrum. Was wäre denn so das Schlechteste, was passieren könnte? Also erstmal könnten sie OS X im iOS 7-Design machen? Das droht?
Also ehrlich gesagt, das iMessage, das könnte gerne irgendwie so aussehen, wie das iMessage on iOS 7. Sehr gerne. Und diese Bubbles kann ich nicht mehr sehen.
So viel besser ist es jetzt auch nicht geworden.
Ja, aber nicht diese 3D-Bubbles, die überhaupt total out of place wirken auf Mac.
Also besser.
Also was schlimm kommen könnte, wäre, dass sie unter Mac OS X noch mehr Features an HFS Plus ran klatschen, ohne dass es signifikant besser wird. Wie auch immer.
Lattenzaunkissen.
Also mehr Cloud, HFS Plus Plus. Was könnten sie noch versemmeln? Das sind eigentlich meine größten Sorgen schon.
Also alles, was mit iCloud zu tun hat, ist Schmerzen. Und wie gesagt, sie könnten einfach die GUI-Optik in dieses Haarstreifen, Nadelstreifendesign da überführen.
Das könnte ein Trainwreck werden.
Am besten gar keine Buttons mehr und so, weißt du?
Keine Schatten. Einfach auch gar keine Fenster mehr.
Das mit diesem Flat-Design irgendwie.
Die letzten Aqua-Bubbles wegmachen?
Was könnten sie noch machen? Wir könnten den App Store so belassen, wie er ist.
Na gut, das ist ja keine Änderung. Wir sagten ja, was können sie noch schlechter machen.
Also noch länger so scheiße lassen, ist schon ganz schön schlimm.
Und ich finde den iTunes-Store auch so grottenschlecht. Das ist unglaublich. Du kannst zum Beispiel nicht...
Da bin ich nie.
Du kannst zum Beispiel nicht... Also ich suche ein iPhone ab. Hier so, Pollenradar, weil ich gerade hier Heuschnupfen bin, ja. Kriegst du eine Liste von iPhone-Apps. Und ich will sortieren nach Bewertung oder irgendwie so. Es ist total... Geht das überhaupt? Keine Ahnung. Ich hab's nicht gefunden, ja. Irgendwie Rumklick, Rumsuch. Das ist so eine beschissene Kaufe-Experience in diesem Laden. Man kann es nicht ausprobieren, man kann es nicht irgendwie sortieren, man kann es nicht ordentlich filtern. Also alles das, was Amazon zum Beispiel richtig gut macht, ja. Wenn du sagst, ich will einen Toaster in der Price-Range, irgendwie soll nur vier oder mehrere Sterne haben, sortiert nach, hast du nicht gesehen, ja. Das wird alles, alles, was du aus irgendeinem Web-Store, aus irgendeinem Default-Web-Store-Framework kriegst, irgendwie all das gibt's weder im App-Store noch im iTunes-Store. Und das kotzt mich auch regelmäßig an, wenn ich dann doch mal wieder versuche, irgendeine App irgendwie zu finden.
Ich weiß noch, mir ist noch was eingefallen. Sie könnten so eine In-Game-Schlumpfbeeren-Währung zu Game Center dazu machen, sodass du quasi Schlumpfbeeren, Game Center Schlumpfbeeren kaufen kannst und die dann in verschiedenen Spielen einsetzen kannst.
War nicht das Gerücht, dass in iOS 8 das Game Center-App verschwindet? Weil das eh keiner benutzt, weil man das direkt über die Programme aufruft?
Würde uns wahrscheinlich nicht auf die Schnelle so auffallen. Das ist genauso, wie wenn sie die Compass-App wegmachen würden. Würde mir auch erstmal nicht auffallen. Oder die Aktien-App. Ja, aber mir würde das nicht auffallen.
Also was mich vor allem madig macht, ist, dass sie die große Gelegenheit, also als sie mit diesem ganzen AppStore-Kram angefangen haben, ganz am Anfang, war das insofern auch ein tolles Ding, weil auf einmal kleine Developer eine echte Chance hatten. Und gar nicht mal nur einzelne so mal, sondern viele auch immer so. Mittlerweile ist aber dieses ganze Premium-Scheißdreck, und du kannst irgendwie deine Software nicht upgraden, das schlägt so dermaßen zurück, dass einfach die jetzt auch alle von der Stange gehen. Also ich kenne irgendwie so viele iOS-Developer, die so als Einzelkämpfer es jetzt ein paar Jahre lang durchgehalten haben, die jetzt alle sagen, es kommt einfach keine Kohle mehr rein, ich suche mir jetzt einen anderen Job, ich gehe zu einer anderen Firma, oder ich mache jetzt hier nur noch Auftragsarbeit und so weiter.
Und da gab es auch schon vor Jahren so ein Artikel, wo beschrieben wurde, dass die meisten Developer verdienen hält, nicht weil sie eine App im Store haben, sondern weil sie bei irgendeiner Bude arbeiten, die irgendeine fancy schmancy Marketing-App irgendwie haben will und die dafür Geld kriegen, dafür, dass sie das koden. Also, richtig direkt Geld verdienen sind wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viele.
Ja, das finde ich halt nicht gut. Weil grundsätzlich ist ja der Store erstmal eine Hilfe gewesen, weil du diese ganzen Lizenznomaden, Copy, Protection, Scheißdreck, was du alles theoretisch an der Backe haben könntest, Abrechnungen, Kunden pflegen und so weiter.
War jetzt aber auch nicht so schlimm, muss ich mal sagen. Ich habe das ja auch mitgemacht und das ist jetzt nicht so, dass es irgendwie...
Das ist nicht unmöglich, aber du würdest dich halt auch lieber aufs Programmieren konzentrieren. Und die Möglichkeit einfach zu sagen, hier ist meine Abkaufzene, das ist ja kein Fehler erstmal. Und vor allem, wenn dann eben das Suchinterface dafür auch noch mitgewachsen wäre, was es nicht ist. Es fühlt sich irgendwie immer noch an wie am ersten Tag eigentlich. Da hat sich irgendwie nichts verbessert.
Mir hat in Novosibirsk der eine Google-Mitarbeiter gesagt, ja, mein Google Play Store ist nicht viel besser. Also, Apps finden...
Nur weil jetzt Google nicht besser ist.
Nein, aber Apps finden in Stores...
Google hat auch einen Vault Garden, den sieht nur keiner, weil damit Werbung vollgeflastet ist.
Apps finden in den Stores ist halt was, was nicht passiert. Also, die Einzigen, die das halbwegs im Griff haben, sind meiner Meinung nach Amazon. Dieses, dieses, dieses... Die Leute, die dir das gekauft haben, die haben auch das gekauft und so weiter. Und bekommst extrem viele Vorschläge, was dich denn sonst noch so interessieren können. Das funktioniert bei denen so halbwegs. Aber letzten Endes, wenn du heute eine App verkaufen willst, wenn du heute ein Buch verkaufen willst, wenn du sonst was verkaufen willst, du musst natürlich dein Marketing auch außerhalb dieser Stores machen. Weil innerhalb des Stores kriegst du halt keine Aufmerksamkeit. Da gibt es halt die Dutzend Apps, die irgendwie bei Apple vorne auf der ersten Seite gefeaturet werden. Die ziehen halt den Jackpot und alle anderen ziehen ihn eben nicht. Und wenn du aber trotzdem Geld damit machen willst, dann musst du halt einen Weg finden außerhalb.
Ja, aber da geht es doch schon mal los. Ich meine, was ist denn das bitte für eine Logik, dass nur so the winner takes it all mäßig, dass du nur das siehst, was sowieso schon gut läuft. Ja, also nicht, dass man sowas nicht vielleicht auch mal sehen wollen würde, aber es ist ja fast das einzige Kriterium außer Apple sucht mal fünf Applikationen aus und featuret die in irgendwas. Aber es gibt keine andere Möglichkeit, keine andere Bewertungsmöglichkeit von Leuten, die etwas hochbringen können. Es gibt da keine User-Auswahl.
Es ist noch viel schlimmer. Also es ist halt, wenn du halt einen fiesen Bug reinbaust und kriegst dann einen Stern Bewertungen ohne Ende, dann war es das halt. Und dann kann dein App-Spiel, was auch immer, halt schnell irgendwie in der Versenkung verschwinden. Weil wenn erstmal die negativen Bewertungen reinkommen, dann war es das. Also das ist so... Aber...
Das ist wirklich alles nicht gut. Und das müsste sich eigentlich ändern, aber tendenziell habe ich mittlerweile auch da die Hoffnung aufgegeben, dass sie das irgendwie sehen. Und was mich daran eigentlich am meisten stört, ist, all die Sachen, auch so diese Kleinigkeiten mit so, ich will mal, ich will einen Film, den ich da habe, den will ich auf dieses Telefon kriegen. Und das geht nicht. Das geht nicht. Es gibt keine Funktion, mit der ich das tun kann. Das ist nicht möglich.
Außer du importierst ihn erst zu iTunes und dann klickst du irgendwo das Häkchen, dass du es aufs Telefon...
Du musst mit iTunes und VLC reinschieben, genau.
Ja, aber wenn du dann irgendwie...
Dann musst du sinken und so.
Ja, aber wenn du deinen Synch über die Cloud machst, dann geht es halt nicht. Es sei denn, du kaufst halt noch den... Wie heißt die Scheiße?
Ich weiß nicht, welche Scheiße du meinst.
iTunes Match. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich auch nur Musik, ne?
Klar, das ist nicht mal Hörbücher.
Was?
Also es gibt einfach keine... Aber iTunes Match ist ja was anderes. iTunes Match ist ja das, was du sowieso schon irgendwo anders hier hast.
Nein, das ist ein Add-on auf das eigentliche Feature, dass du immer deinen Kram dazu hast.
Nein, aber wenn du Musik im iTunes Store kaufst, dann kannst du das auch auf dem Device runterladen, noch mal vom iTunes Store. Das ist nicht so ein Problem. Da brauchst du doch keinen iTunes Match für.
Ja, also stattdessen musst du dir halt irgendeine App kaufen, die irgendeinen Aspekt irgendwie macht. So, ja, was weiß ich hier, so Bittorrensyn, da haben wir ja schon ein paar Mal drüber gesprochen. VLC, klar gibt es irgendeine App, aber dann liegt dieser Film in der App. Und nicht auf meinem Phone, wo ich mit jeder App drauf zugreifen kann und auch will. Mit dem Playerwahl und so weiter.
Man will eine demilitarisierte Zonahme auf dem iPhone, oder so ein Storage, wo man Sachen reinschieben kann, wo sich die anderen Apps wieder rausholen können. Es muss ja gar nicht direkt von App zu App sein, aber so eine Art Zwischenspeicher irgendwie.
Ja, und ich meine, wenn ich sowieso die Möglichkeit habe, das Fall... Das klingt wie eine gute Idee.
Ein Filesystem, noch nie gehört.
Es müsste ja noch nicht mal ein Filesystem sein. Object Storage.
Ein Blob-System.
Ein Finder.
Object Storage, alles so. Hauptsache, man ist mal der Master der Daten. Aber es geht natürlich nicht, weil dann wäre ja ihr Business-Modell in Gefahr. Nämlich ihr iTunes-Business-Modell.
Wenn ich weiter mal ein ganz anderes Business-Modell eingefahren habe, dann kaufe ich mir kein iPhone mehr.
Ja, und der Punkt ist, an der Stelle arbeiten sie halt gegen den User. Also ihre Politik an der Stelle ist einfach gegen ihre Kunden. Und ich finde, an der Stelle bricht einfach der Abfall in zwei Hälften.
Das Problem ist, glaube ich, dass wir da in einer Minderheit sind noch.
Na, das Problem haben theoretisch alle.
Ja, aber interessiert das nicht.
Mich fragen Leute sowas. Und ich weiß nicht, was ich sagen soll.
Kauft euch Android, sagst du. Beschwert euch bei Apple und kauft dann Android. Ja, das ist das Problem. Und Apple weiß das. Die haben uns am Sack.
Nee, aber weißt du so, dieses Bild hier, 1984, und wir zeigen euch, warum 1984 nicht wie 1984 sein wird. Und hier alles frei und Power to the User und Power Macintosh, weißt du, diese Commercials, so Power und Power, Power, Power.
The Power to be your best.
Das waren so die Commercials, die sind immer noch ganz oben in meiner Favoritenliste von damals. Und irgendwie ist es halt so, jetzt fühlt es sich eher so als Sklave des Systems halt, ne? Und nicht so als Commander in Charge Power User.
Ich fühle mich als Sklave der Cloud.
Ja, die Sklaven-Cloud.
Ich meine, du musst ja auch mal sehen, das iPhone ist ja ein cooles Gerät, es ist schnell, es hat irgendwie alles, was ich will, aber es wird halt künstlich irgendwie beschränkt. Und ich könnte so viel mehr Spaß damit haben. Allein schon jedes Mal, wenn ich halt wirklich ein Bild von meinem iPhone auf meinen Rechner kriegen will. Also Airdrop wäre es ja gewesen, es ist ja alles da, nur dass das eine Airdrop nicht das Gleiche ist wie das andere Airdrop. Also schicke ich mir eine Mail, das ist doch total bekloppt, oder?
Ja, ich meine, wenn du da was hindropst, wo dropst du es denn dann hin eigentlich?
Ja, in deinem...
Also ich meine, wenn du jetzt von einem Phone aufs andere Phone airdropst, wo landet es dann?
In die Foto-Roll wahrscheinlich?
Na ich hab ja nur ein Phone, du meinst ja nicht, was zu dir schicke.
Ja, aber ich kann auch im Prinzip eine beliebige, kann man, ich meine, funktioniert das Airdrop nur mit Fotos?
Nur bestimmte Sachen gehen, glaube ich, aber...
Nur bestimmte Sachen, na toll.
Na, die Frage wäre halt, wenn es von Mac zu Phone geht, was passiert, wenn du da einen Target Set rüberdropst oder so?
Ja, geht ja nicht, hier ist keiner zu sehen. Musst du aufmachen.
Ja, ich benutze dieses iPad selten.
Und alle anderen in Berlin lassen es jetzt mal aus, sonst geht das hier nicht. Ah, hier einen sehe ich jetzt hier. Okay, den Roddi sehe ich. Ich klicke mal auf Roddi. Klicke. Waiting, waiting, waiting.
Oh, was ist denn das?
Wo ist denn dieses AirDrop?
Malaga Battery.
Hier in deinem Info-Screen.
Ja, so iOS 6, da hast du das natürlich nicht.
Das ist nicht iOS 6, du Penner.
Hier in diesem, was du so hoch swipen kannst, ja. Da ist es nicht.
Ist das nur auf dem iPhone?
Hast du Bluetooth an?
Nee, oder ist dein iPad zu alt? Ich dachte, das gibt es auch auf dem iPad. Also hier guck mal.
Habt ihr mal einen schicken?
Das sieht hier so aus, das Symbol.
Also mal, ich hole das andere Device.
Also mit Roddy hat es gerade locker funktioniert. Ich habe ihm was hingeschoben und er hat mir was zurückgeschoben. Hier, da muss es sein. Das hier muss ich mit drin setzen. Das ist doch das, oder nicht?
Nee, das ist so alt.
Auf dem iPhone 4 geht es auch nicht?
Ich glaube, es geht schon auf dem 4GS nicht.
Jetzt siehst du hier mal den Strom raus.
Wo ist dein Bild jetzt gelandet, Roddy? Einfach, einfach hat er einmal in den Restaurant gehangen.
Ich mache mal Fenster auf hier. Ich lasse mal was von der iCloud rein.
Aber was kannst du denn da auswählen? Nur Bilder oder was?
Ich gehe jetzt hier zu meinen Bildern, klicke da drauf.
Nein, weg mit den Bildern. Bildern ist mir einfach zu blöd.
Ja, dann?
Ja, deine Filme irgendwie, was auch immer.
Ja, Songs wird jetzt nicht gehen, nehme ich mal an.
Ja, also auch in Airdrop hast du sozusagen nur das, was global vorliegt. Aber du kannst in dieses globale eigentlich nichts anderes reintun, außer Bilder.
Airdrop ist doch auch accessible von den Apps oder nicht?
Text geht, glaube ich, auch oder sowas. Ich glaube, du kannst zum Beispiel in deinen Notes oder so deine Textpumplette zum Beispiel überschicken, glaube ich. Zeig mal her.
New Note hier, Test, so, Done. Dann gehe ich jeden auf Schicken.
Oder Context kannst du drücken.
Das ist ein Drama. Wir reden hier von dem iPhone und wir, mit 20, 25 Jahren Computing-Spills, sind nicht in der Lage, überhaupt die grundlegendste eingeschränkteste Funktionalität zu realisieren oder zu verstehen. Das ist doch wirklich kacke.
Zum Beispiel Context. Einen Kontakt könnte man ja auch mal zu einem anderen Sender, aber ich glaube, das geht auch schon nicht.
Also Apple will für mich entscheiden, was ich durch die Gegend schicke. Das ist einfach, das geht nicht. Das ist einfach, nee. Just don't.
Share, Contact, AirDrop, doch das geht aber auch hier. Schon wieder der Rodka, immer der gleiche. Zack hier.
Hä, was ist denn das? Honda.
Honda-Chintola.
Tempelhofer Weg, alles klar. Wenn ich meine Honda brauche.
Weil es gibt derzeit irgendwie nur Apple-Fuck oder Google-Fuck. Aber gefickt wirst du immer.
Na, es gibt noch Lumi und Lumin, Lumo, Lumo, Limo.
Aber Microsoft, hab ich gehört, wird jetzt wieder cool. Die Männer alten sind immer cooler als der Rest. Da ist die Temperatur gewohnt.
Ich finde das schon mal eine nennenswerte...
Ehrlich gesagt ist mir das scheißegal, ob der Chef schwitzt oder nicht. Die sollen ordentlichen Scheiß bauen.
Mir war das nie egal.
Vielleicht hat der Bäumer einfach nur aluminium-freies Deodorant benutzt. Deswegen hat er mehr transpiriert.
Ganz ehrlich.
Nur weil Steve nicht geschwitzt hat. Also jetzt stell dich mal nicht so an.
Was hat dein Grund, warum du einen schwarzen Rollkrankenpolimator hast?
Vielleicht war der Innen mit PVC ausgeschlagen, dass man es nicht so sieht.
Mal ehrlich, dieser Bäumer war für mich ein Grund, mich nicht damit auseinanderzusetzen mit der Welt.
Ich fand eigentlich sein Gekokse viel schlimmer. Sein Gekokse. Dass der Typ immer auf Koks war. Wenn man ihn irgendwie gesehen hat, hatte man immer das Gefühl, der Typ ist gerade nicht hundertprozentig anwesend, sondern überdreht oder unterdreht.
Er war auf jeden Fall sehr unausgeglichen.
Wie heißt denn der? Wer ist denn der neue? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Nadella, Nadella, Nadella? Hat sich noch nicht viele Namen gemacht. Satya Nadella heißt er doch, oder? Doch, der hat schon ordentlich gewirbelt, oder nicht?
Doch, der hat da schon einige Posten umgesetzt und neu gemacht und so. Das musst du halt machen.
Erst mal ein paar Sachen Steven.
Erst mal ein paar Penner rausschmeißen, die ich schon mal gemerkt hab.
Die Freunde werden erst mal ins Amt gehoben und die Gegner werden erst mal geköpft, alle, ne?
Ich wundere mich hier, warum die Luft nicht besser wird. Das Fenster ist ja schon wieder zugeklappt.
Das ist viel einfach zu...
Scheinbar hast du gar nicht aufgemacht.
Bin ich schon so betrunken vom Bier?
Wahrscheinlich. Ja, also so komplett unsympathisch ist mir dieser Nadella auf jeden Fall nicht.
Du meinst also Microsoft wäre eine Alternative, jetzt wo die auch nicht mehr so riesengroß sind? Ja, aber mal ehrlich, die wollen doch auch alles über die Cloud machen.
Du meinst, mit Ballmer ist jetzt die Hefte der Besatzung gegangen?
Also welche... Welche Firma macht dann nicht alles über die Cloud?
Du, das mit der Cloud, das werden wir eh nicht mehr los. Also ich hab auch erst mal nichts grundsätzlich gegen Clouds. Ich finde nur, jeder sollte eine haben. Und große Clouds meint wegen auch alles, man muss da bloß noch viel Lösungen finden für die Probleme, die das grundsätzlich mit sich bringt. Allen voran natürlich Sicherheit, Privatsphäre. Zuverlässigkeit, Alternativen, Backup etc.
Solange alles mit OpenSSL verschlüsselt ist, mach ich mir keine Sorgen.
Aber man kann jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass unsere Leben durch die Cloud-Systeme jetzt so viel schlechter geworden sind. Mein kompletter Computing-Alltag ist Cloud-basiert.
Doch, kann man sagen. Mein Leben ist durch Clouds schlechter geworden, weil dadurch, dass die so dieses Cloud-Zeugs pushen wollen, kümmern die sich um nichts anderes mehr. Und ich hätte gerne dieses andere, um das sie sich jetzt nicht mehr kümmern. Deswegen ist mein Leben schlechter geworden. Ohne die Clouds könnte ich meine Bilder wahrscheinlich ganz einfach rüberschieben. Geht aber nicht, weil ich soll ja die Cloud benutzen. So gesehen ist es schlechter.
Okay, da bin ich auch ganz bei dir. Aber ich sag ja erstmal, grundsätzlich gibt es auch viele Dinge, die man nur über eine Wolke realisieren kann. Oder die, wenn sie über Regen...
Hagel? Was meinst du jetzt so? Gib mal ein Beispiel.
Dropbox zum Beispiel. Also Dropbox halte ich zum Beispiel für eine der sinnvollsten und großartigsten Dinge, die mir seit langem untergekommen sind.
Aber wo fängt denn Cloud an und wo hört Webservice auf?
Cloud ist halt, wenn du da eine nennenswerte große Infrastruktur hast, die ihm auch meine Daten vorhält. Ist egal, wie du es nennst, mir ist es egal.
Weil Geocity ist auch schon ein Cloud?
Dienstleistung auf Basis des Internets, die einfach Sachen für mich tut. Und im Prinzip haben auch Webseiten sowas für mich getan. Die haben halt meine Visitenkarte, meine Projekte, meine Informationen im Netz vorgehalten, ohne dass ich meinen Rechner aufklappen musste. Das war ja auch schon mal was ganz Tolles. Und jetzt geht es halt noch ein bisschen weiter. Und die Integration umfasst halt mittlerweile alles. Alle Rechner und vor allem eben auch diese ganzen Smartphones. Und Dropbox ist so ein Dienst, also ich glaube, wenn man jetzt mal alles abschalten würde da draußen. Wo würdest du als erstes da fragen, dass es bitte wieder eingeschaltet wird? So ist Dropbox sicherlich so in den Top 10. Und ich sage jetzt auch gar nicht spezifisch, Dropbox, das Produkt Dropbox und nur Dropbox geht, sondern alles, was im Prinzip eine ähnliche oder zumindest vergleichbare Dienstleistungen bereitzustellen in der Lage ist.
Kannst du hier einen Transporter hinstellen?
Ja, könnte ich irgendwie.
Da brauchst du ja keinen Dropbox.
Ja, aber dann sind halt meine Transporter kaputt und dann geht es irgendwie irgendwas nicht.
Klar, Infrastruktur, die du selber machst, musst du auch selber erwarten.
Ja, ja, eben. Es hat ja auch viel damit zu tun, dass ich nicht selber derart bin.
Wir sind da Freund von dezentralen Lösungen oder nicht? Und Cloud ist halt nur mal ultrazentral. Ich meine, Apple hat da wieviele 100 Millionen an Cloud.
Ich bin auch ein Freund von dezentralen Lösungen. Das heißt noch lange nicht, dass ich ein Feind von zentralen Lösungen bin. Ich kann beides mögen.
Das fällt mir schwer.
Man muss halt immer das Richtige für den richtigen Einsatzzweck nehmen. Und manchmal sind halt auch solche Sachen sinnvoll. Man muss natürlich dann schauen, ob das deinem Trust-Level entspricht. Das ist eine ganz andere Fragestellung. Aber auch ich könnte viele Dinge anderen anbieten über irgendwie eine Wolke. Ich könnte mir zum Beispiel so eine Podcast-Cloud auch ganz wunderbar vorstellen. Ja, würde wahrscheinlich auch eine Menge Leute Probleme lösen, die du derzeit hast. Mit WordPress und so ein Quatsch.
Wieso gibt es doch die WordPress-Cloud?
Ja, aber da kannst du nicht Plugins installieren.
Und nicht?
Du kannst nur installieren, was die da wollen.
Nacktes PHP.
Wobei, WordPress dort kommt, ist schon mal ein ganz anderes Problem. Das ist überhaupt so das Problem bei dieser ganzen Totalintegration, dass jetzt so diese großen Firmen irgendwie alles machen, ist auch so, dass sie einfach fast keine Bereiche mehr haben, wo mein Interesse mit ihrem Interesse kollidiert. Das haben wir jetzt bei Apple schon schön durchinteriert, aber das ist bei den anderen jetzt auch nicht so sehr viel anders. Ist auch bei Google nicht anders. Die Hand haben das plus anders. Ja, bei Google da stören dann halt die Dienste einfach. Hast du toll gefunden, hast du super deinen Workloader abgestellt. Scheiß drauf, weg. Mögen wir nicht mehr hier Google Reader gehen weg.
Mich hat auch keiner gefragt, ob ich nicht noch ein bisschen Ping benutzen will. Wie ist das, Ping?
Wie ist das andere, Google Wave?
Das war nicht so schlimm. Das war ja so kurz da und so schnell wieder weg. Das hat doch gar keiner gemerkt.
Ja gut, das ist bei Wave aber auch nicht anders.
Das war schon ein bisschen länger da, oder?
Ja.
Ja, Wave war gefühlte 10 Pings lang.
Ich glaube, Ping lief sogar länger als Wave.
Ja, aber es hatte nur ein Zehntel so lange User.
Userstunden gemessen, hatte Ping wahrscheinlich wirklich ein Zehntel von Wave.
Ich frage mich jetzt ernsthaft, ob so diese letzte Dekade, auf die du ja eigentlich anspielst, Dennis, ob die überhaupt noch mal wiederkommt.
Wie meinst du, ob die letzte Dekade, die du anspielt hast, die letzte Dekade war alles toll? Nein, eigentlich geht es schon seit 10.5 abwärts, 10.6 irgendwie. Also das ist abwärts, aber es kommen mehr Restriktionen, wo man sich denkt, die müssten eigentlich nicht sein, die haben da eine andere Idee von Workflow oder von Arbeitsweise, als ich habe.
Also was mich halt stört, ist, dass du zentrale OS-Features hast, die nur funktionieren, wenn Apple seine Cloud im Griff hat, was sie traditionell nicht haben. Also das ist so...
Also Apple gerade ist doch mehr...
Wenn das alles nur Add-ons wären, die keinem wehtun, wenn sie nicht da sind, dann wäre das alles okay. Aber da das ja teilweise wirklich zentrale Features sind oder zumindest als solche verkauft werden, das nervt halt.
Ja, ich meine, wenn Apple jetzt gesprengt wird, dann kannst du noch nicht mal deinen Computer neu installieren.
Zum Beispiel. Oder dein iPhone. Die sind dann alle am Arsch.
Die sagen einfach, Apple gibt es nicht mehr, also gibt es mich auch nicht.
Ja, du kannst das wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal wieder freischalten.
Das meinte ich ja, die Aktivierung.
Die Aktivierung, genau.
Das ist bei Google auch nicht anders.
Mag sein.
Oder die müssen sich doch auch aktivieren.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, kannst du routen und so weiter, ein Pipapo, ein eigenes OS darauf installieren. Super, kann man alles machen. Man kann jetzt auch irgendwie immer noch den Open-Source-Way gehen und sagen, ich ignoriere diesen ganzen Mainstream-Quatsch.
Mache ich alles mit OpenSSL.
Genau, mach mal was mit OpenSSL. Aber dann ist es halt auch gleich nicht mehr so einfach, wie es heute ist.
Die Welt ist nicht perfekt.
Die Welt ist nicht perfekt, aber ich finde, Apple muss sich da einfach auch mal neu ausrichten. Oder wieder mal neu ausrichten. Und zwar am besten an mir.
Ja, weniger Krautwagen, mehr geiles Felsystem. Und jetzt könnt ihr mir, also wenn ihr Hörer da draußen, mir jetzt noch einen Schmerznagel ziehen könntet, der mich bei Mavericks in den Wahnsinn treibt. Das ist hier ganz großartig. In Mavericks haben sie angefangen, dass wenn man ein Terminal-Fenster zu macht, dir immer so ein Dialog entgegenzufeifern, ob du den Prozess terminieren willst oder nicht.
Das war schon immer so. Du musst die Optionen ausschalten.
Wo ist diese Option?
Ab Willkommar und dann Quit und Asking und so. Wie heißt das hier? Bei Shell bestimmt. When the shell exits, close if the shell exited cleanly. Also gehst du ab Willkommar, dann auf den Shell-Reiter da, da und dann den da einstellen. Aber den hast du schon eingestellt. Den mittleren hast du, oder? Den habe ich auch.
Und da ist bei mir Screen und T-Mox eingetragen.
Ja, bei mir auch, genau.
Bei mir fragt er total oft, zum Beispiel.
Before closing, never.
Ich habe das Fenster auf. Eine SSH ist ja schon zu einem anderen Host. Ich mache Apple W. Er sagt irgendwie, do you want it?
Da läuft ja auch noch was.
Weil eine SSH läuft, dann müsstest du entweder hier SSH eintragen oder da auf never.
Okay, never.
Ja, aber du willst, dass aus Versehen deine Fenster zugehen können, obwohl du da noch was offen hast?
Ja, wenn ich Apple W sage, soll das scheiß Fenster zugehen.
Na dann stell dir das ein. Dann geht doch das scheiß Fenster zu.
Ach, sehr gut. Ich habe nämlich schon...
Du darfst mich flattern.
Okay, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt Apple W meine Produktivität steigt um den Faktor 0,1, das wäre...
Zehn Prozent, das ist schon eine ganze Menge.
Manchmal ist dieser Podcast doch zu was gebrauchen.
Zehn Prozent.
Wann ist denn jetzt eigentlich diese WWDC?
1.
Juni-Woche.
Oh, der Freeways-Decolon hat nicht gebaut. Ach, das ist ja noch lange hin.
Das ist noch eine Weile hin. Ich finde es aber trotzdem relativ früh. Ich habe das irgendwie in Erinnerung, dass es sonst später war. Aber es ist vielleicht...
Es ist nicht mal in zwei Monaten schon.
Da täuscht mich meine... Bin ich eh in Italien.
Ja.
Bringst du uns wieder iPhones mit?
Kann ich machen. Ich glaube nur, dass es diesmal nicht mehr so viel bringt.
Wann war das? Das war 2009 oder wann? Fünf Jahre her. Meine Fresse. Das Vierer muss ich mir noch aus London mitbringen lassen.
Der Apple Store Rom, der war auch echt irgendwie...
Wir sollten noch einen Barometer haben für unser Level of Apple Excitement. Also so gefühlt geht es die letzten sechs bis zwölf Monate ja stetig bergab. Also ich kann mich schon erinnern, bei Mavericks, als wir da so gemutmaßt haben, haben wir auch schon alle so de la me.
Ja, das ist ja auch nicht. Da ist alles schon eine Menge cool. Also Batterielaufzeit zum Beispiel bei Mavericks ist wirklich...
Mavericks war ein Improvement auf jeden Fall.
Ja, aber da waren auch so Sachen dabei, die einfach nervig sind.
Das konnte iOS 7 nicht ausgleichen.
Ich will ein neues Textdokument aufmachen und der fragt mich, ob ich das in der Cloud öffnen möchte.
Das kannst du auch ändern, dann gibt es auch so ein Setting.
iOS 7 ist unter der Haube, es sind einige coole Sachen drin, aber eben nur unter der Haube.
Ja, du, wenn du in deinen iCloud-Settings, habe ich auch gerade noch gemacht, weil ich gesehen habe, dass es wieder aktiv ist nach meinem Clean Install. Documents in Data, wenn du das Häkchen da komplett wegmachst, dann fragst du, wo, wo, wo?
Es gibt auch irgendwo noch ein Setting, wo du deinen Default setzen kannst, aber ich habe jetzt auch gerade...
Echt, hier gibt es iCloud. Und dann mache ich einfach alle aus jetzt, ganz einfach, oder?
Hast du documents in Data an?
Ich mache ja hier, ich mache einfach alle aus.
Gucken wir mal, welche Programme das benutzen, weil wenn du es ausmachst...
Documents werden jetzt da gelöscht. Ich hoffe, dieses Scheiß iOutbank schiebt da nichts hin. Und Reminders und Calendars und Contacts. Delete from Mac? Und Contacts hat er wieder eingeschaltet, dieses Sau. Na, mal gucken, was passiert. Ich hoffe, ich habe jetzt nichts gelöscht.
Oh, Linkinus hat sich gerade verabschiedet.
So, wenn ich jetzt einen Text aufmache, dann geht es sofort. Du kannst deinen Flatter behalten, den kriegst du nämlich gerade wieder.
Ah, geil. Willkommen bei der Freak Show Selbsthilfe-Gruppe.
Ja, hier werden sie geholfen.
Aber ich bin mir sicher, dass es noch ein Setting gibt, explizit für dieses Wo speichert er den Scheiß denn zuerst ab?
Ist es möglicherweise ein hidden Setting?
Also ich habe es schon ausgeschaltet, es hat funktioniert.
Ja, du hast jetzt den kompletten Storage in iCloud abgeschaltet.
Nee, für Text and Documents.
Wo?
Nein, das hat der Hucke gerade gezeigt. Also hier gibt es hier diesen iCloud-Dingens, da werden die ganzen Sachen aufgelistet und den habe ich ausgemacht. Also ich habe auch andere Sachen ausgemacht, aber der war es.
Ja, aber das bezieht sich nicht auf Textdokumente.
Aber mit diesem Häkchen ändert es sich sofort. Also dann hast du nicht mehr diesen komischen Dialog, wo du das auswählen kannst und so weiter.
Ja, aber dann können halt deine Programme auch nichts mehr auf iCloud auflegen, wenn du das willst.
Die dürfen gar nichts.
Ich will das nicht. Also ich benutze ja iCloud tatsächlich zum Adressbuch. Weil wir das sonst so... Also weil sie es halt ausgebaut hatten aus dem iCloud.
Nee, haben sie wieder eingebaut in 1092. Das soll wohl wieder gehen. Das ist auch so eine Entscheidung, die eindeutig keinen Sinn macht. Können sich die Leute nach Hause suchen, ob sie lokal sinken wollen oder über iCloud. Aber da machen sie ein Feature kaputt, was es schon immer gegeben hat.
Also ich benutze das mit Textedit. Wenn ich da mal... Das kann man schnell mal Text aufmachen, tippt irgendwas rein und wenn du dann auf einem anderen Rechner bist, dann kannst du das irgendwie aus iCloud wieder rausziehen und dann hast du deine Notiz.
Eine Sache, die sie noch schlechter machen können, in der nächsten Mac OS Version, sie könnten noch mehr Features in iTunes einbauen.
Ja, aber iTunes hat ja jetzt mit Mac OS erstmal nichts zu tun. Das ist ja dein eigenes OS.
Ja, ja, stimmt. Das hat wahrscheinlich auch 70 Millionen Zeilen Code mittlerweile, dieses iTunes.
Am besten sie bauen Time Machine in iTunes ein. Oh, geile Idee. Was sie übrigens auch noch schlechter machen könnten, wäre, dass Time Machine noch öfter auf dem Server sein Backup kaputt macht. Nicht nur alle sechs Wochen, sondern noch öfter.
Aber das hatte ich wirklich jetzt schon lange nicht mehr.
Aber du benutzt jetzt auch deine ZFS Netatalk Time Machine?
Ja, was da drunter ist, ist ja egal. Aber ich nutze dieses Netatalk in der neuesten Generation jetzt. Wo sind die? 3.1.1 oder sowas inzwischen? Oder was 3.3.1? Ich habe keine Ahnung, das ist neuesten auf jeden Fall.
Also ich habe da mal wieder Probleme mit, aber es ist auch egal.
Ne, dieses iTunes, das würde ich so gerne loswerden auch. Das ist so ein Krebsgeschwör am Hintern dieses Mac OS.
Haben wir noch Themen?
Haben wir ordentlich abgerendet heute, oder?
Ich glaube, wir haben eigentlich ganz viele Themen. Allerdings sitzt der Stachel der Frustration sehr tief bei uns.
Ich mache jetzt mal was, was wir noch gar nicht hatten, glaube ich.
Ich habe auch noch ein schönes kleines Thema.
Ich empfehle mal ein Buch.
Ein Buch. Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy?
Na so richtig Papier, nee. Das heißt The Martian, wie der Marsianer. Ich weiß nicht, gibt es wahrscheinlich noch keine deutsche Übersetzung zu. Als ich im Februar in Portland war, da war ich auch wieder bei Paul. Paul City of Books. Wer mal nach Portland fährt, der muss unbedingt in diesem Buchladen gewesen sein. Das ist der größte Buchladen, den ich kenne, und der ist auch sehr sympathisch. Die Regale stellen sie ein bisschen eng. Aber ansonsten ist es ein sehr schöner Buchladen. Und die hatten dort so aufgestellt als großes, ja, hier Tipp und so weiter, das Buch The Martian von Andy Ware, also W-E-I-R, geschrieben. Und zwar geht es um einen Astronauten, der Teil einer Mars-Mission ist. Irgendwie so eine Handvoll Astronauten, ich glaube sechs Stück, landen auf dem Mars. Und am sechsten Tag kommt ein Sandsturm auf, der so heftig ist, dass es so aussieht, als würde er das Raumschiff umschmeißen, mit dem sie wieder zurückfliegen wollen. Also sind sie da in Panik aus ihrem Habitat raus in dieses Raumschiff. Und einer der Astronauten, Mark Watney, wird von der Antenne getroffen, die an dem Habitat dran ist und sich losgerissen hat. Und zwar so getroffen, dass irgendwie im Bauch und sein Live-Support-System flöten geht und der Raumanzug gibt keinen Signal mehr ab und so weiter. Denn ist natürlich, den Sandsturm sieht man nicht allzu viel. Die restliche Crew findet ihn nicht wieder und muss darauf hin, dass dieses Live-Support-System halt nicht mehr funktioniert. Damit müssen sie davon ausgehen, dass er tatsächlich tot ist, weil das keine ordentlichen Werte mehr liefert und so weiter. Und die fliegen halt dann ohne ihn weg, weil sie ihn auch nicht wiederfinden. Und das Teil ist schon kurz davor, umzukippen. Und dann ist er aber nicht tot, sondern liegt da halt, als der Sturm zu Ende ist, irgendwie im Sand. Seine Wunde im Bauch hat irgendwie den Raumanzug zugeblutet. Also er verliert auch keine weitere Luft. Und er schafft es irgendwie wieder zurück, ins Habitat zu kommen. Aber jetzt sitzt er halt auf dem Mars fest.
Und Habitat ist so was wie BioWorld 2, was halt so selbst...
Ja, Habitat ist so ein Zelt.
Mit Essen und Zeug oder wie? Mit Pflanzen und Schnickschnack oder was?
Nee, mit Pflanzen erstmal nicht. Na, das ist halt so ein...
Aber wie lange hält man denn da drin aus?
So ein Zelt mit halt so ein bisschen Platz und so ein bisschen Luft und so Regenerationssysteme und Solarzellen gibt es und so weiter. Ich will nicht so viel verraten.
Und du hast das Buch schon komplett durch?
Ich hab das Buch schon komplett durch.
Und du sagst, das ist cool.
Das Geile an dem Buch ist, mir ist an dem Buch nicht ein Stück Technik aufgefallen, das noch erfunden werden müsste. Es ist also eigentlich alles komplett realistisch. Wenn man heute einen Mars-Flug machen würde, er würde wahrscheinlich so aussehen. Da ist also keine Laserschwerter und sonst was und auch keine Dimensionstore und nichts, sondern es ist alles mit existierender Technik.
Wo ist der Total Perspective Vortex?
Also das Ganze ist eher so Science-Fact als Science-Fiction. Wer so etwas interessiert, ich fand es extrem spannend. Also es ist wirklich bis zum Schluss extrem spannend.
Dann kannst du mir deine Kopie leihen.
Nee, ich habe das tatsächlich als Todbaum. Weiß ich nicht.
Kindle Edition, nee, könnt ihr behalten.
Ich will das Papier.
Hast du das gefunden? Dann schmeiß mal in den Chat.
Da hebst du gleich einen Affiliate-Link drauf.
Ich will ja kein Dings hier hochkriechen. 50 Dollar. Gehen wir erstmal nach amazon.de.
Ich habe auch noch eine kleine Empfehlung oder einen Tipp. Und zwar gibt es gerade einen Mac-Heist-Bundle. Und Mac-Heist-Bundle sind für mich meistens eher unexciting. Aber in der aktuellen Version gibt es Screenflow. Und Screenflow kostet an sich sonst 99 Dollar. Und wer Screencasts aufnehmen will, da gibt es so ein paar Tools. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die anderen nochmal alle hießen, aber Screenflow ist eins dieser ganz vorne mit dabei Tools. Ganz toll ist das. Und das habe ich auch hier für meine FreeBSD Screencast benutzt. Und wie gesagt, ich meine, das Mac-Heiss-Bundle kostet 1999. Das heißt, man hat da irgendwie 70 Dollar schon mal direkt für Screenflow gespart. Die anderen Tools, die sehen, wie ich schon meinte, eher unexciting aus. Wobei, da gibt es einen Font-Viewer. Also wer den Font-Explorer damals noch von Linotype kennt oder... Also ich meine, das Font-Book von Apple, das ist ja mittlerweile so okay. Aber irgendwie zum Font-Brausen auch nicht so richtig cool geeignet. Und jetzt habe ich hier in diesem Mac-Hise-Bundle dieses Fonts gesehen. Also so heißt das Tool. Und das sieht eigentlich ganz schick aus. Das muss ich mir mal auschecken, weil das kostet selber auch nur 10 Dollar. Also ich habe Screenflow kürzlich erst für meine FreeBSD-Casts gekauft. Deswegen brauche ich das Mac-Hise-Bundle auch jetzt nicht direkt. Aber ja, wer vielleicht mal Screencasts machen will...
Oh, da ist iSale dabei.
Was ist ein iSale?
Das Konkurrenzprodukt von meinem vorherigen Arbeitgeber. Das ist auch nicht so toll, aber es hat irgendwann vor unzähligen Jahren mal einen Design Award gewonnen. Wie auch immer das passiert ist. Oh ja, Boink's TV ist dabei. Das war nicht schlecht.
Hat sich das eigentlich irgendwie noch weiterentwickelt?
Was? Boink's TV?
Also Screenflow ist wirklich gut. Das kann man echt mal sagen. Ich mache zwar nicht viele Screencasts, aber das ist so eine Software, in die ich sofort reingekommen bin, in der ich mich auch überhaupt nicht groß auseinandersetzen musste und die einfach so funktioniert hat, wie man sich das gedacht hat und irgendwie alles auch noch ein bisschen toller macht. Und man wundert sich eigentlich eher über den Funktionsumfang. Also Screencast-Software, das klingt jetzt erstmal so, ja, nimm auf und dann hast du da so einen Pfeil und dann musst du sehen, wie du klarkommst. Nein, da ist noch so, ich kenne sogar Leute, die editieren ihre Videos in Screenflow.
Das kann ich allerdings wiederum nicht so verstehen, weil dieser Timeline-Editor, der ist so ein bisschen beschränkt, finde ich. Also da so präzise so Schnibbels rauszuschnibbeln, das finde ich immer so ein bisschen...
Ich frage, worum es einem geht, ob es jetzt unbedingt immer so um Präzise geht oder wie das überhaupt alles so vom Workflow funktioniert und ich fand das irgendwie bisher alles immer sehr eindeutig.
Also von der Usability ist es super, aber so... Also Videoschnitt würde ich da niemals drin versuchen.
Ja gut, Videoschnitt hat ja häufig auch eher was mit Anfang und Ende und die richtigen Spuren und Ton an die richtige Stelle und Texttafeln davor und sowas. Also so...
Eins der Killer-Features von Final Cut Pro ist ja dieses Video- und Audio-Clips-Synken, Autosynken, das ist echt, das muss jede Software haben, die mit Audio und Video zu tun hat. Also das hätte ich auch gerne in Reaper, das hätte ich gerne überall, wo man so mit Ton und Videospuren zusammen... Einfach hier, pass auf, Stapelspuren, mach die mal übereinander und zwar genau. Ah, das ist wirklich eine richtig geile Feature.
Also sozusagen selber Ton mit mehreren Videos aufgenommen und anhand des Audios werden sie dann synchronisiert sozusagen?
Du kannst halt zum Beispiel, du könntest einen Videoclip haben, dann nimmst du es mit dem Mikrofon auf, mit deinem iPhone, mit so einem Zoom-HD-Recorder, schmeißt das alles zusammen in deine Library, sagst, synkt mal, und dann hast du einen Clip, wo alles übereinander liegt. Und das ist geil.
Ach, er synkt den Ton von dem Video über Schrott, Mikro aufgenommen, zusammen mit dem richtig aufgehendem Ton. Aber jetzt nicht anhand des Bildes?
Oder multiple Videoclips, die sind dann alle sozusagen, du kritisierst die dann in die Timeline, dann hast du die übereinander und kannst dir aussuchen, welchen Clip du jetzt zu der Zeit spielen willst und so. Ja, aber das ist in Screenflow nicht drin. Hätte ich aber auch gerne, weil da habe ich ja den Ton auch wieder auf eine extra Spur aufgenommen. Und das dann mit der anderen Spur zu synken war auch wieder ein bisschen...
Mr. Mo sagt gerade, ich soll noch mal für die Show Notes Werbung machen.
Show Notes Werbung.
Show Notes Mitschreiben macht glücklich.
Jetzt, wo die Sendung gleich vorbei ist.
Machen das zu wenig gerade?
Keine Ahnung, er hat gesagt, ich soll Show Notes Werbung machen. Mach ich natürlich.
Ah, hier, Tim, hier, geiles Thema noch. Du, ich ziehe aus unserem Themetopf noch ein geiles Thema. Richtig heiß, ganz, ganz heiß.
Das sind so Dinge, die manche Leute meiden.
Echt, gibt's die?
Ja, die gibt's. Die denken, weiß ich nicht. Also es gibt Leute, die finden Regular Expressions zu kompliziert. Und wie es bei Magnum damals immer so schön hieß, wenn Tom Selleck nach einem Themenwechsel in der Sendung mit seinem Ferrari über die Landstraße fährt und so aus dem Off spricht, ich weiß, was sie jetzt sagen wollen und sie haben recht.
Also ich finde, Regular Expressions sind auch manchmal für Leute, die gerne knobeln. So kleine Puzzlespiele.
Was ist es für Leute, die nicht wissen, was es ist?
Das ist ein Dialekt von Brainfuck.
Wir können erstmal fragen. Kennt irgendjemand Regular Expressions nicht?
Tja, das ist so eine, wie würde ich das zusammenfassen? Das ist so eine Syntax, um Muster in Text zu beschreiben.
Wobei Syntax jetzt den Begriff wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen weitstretcht.
Man könnte es auch anders formulieren. Man benutzt Zeichen, wie sie auf Computertastaturen vorhanden sind, um bestimmte Konstruktionen von Wörtern oder anderen Zeichen, wie sie auf Tastaturen vorhanden sind, in einem Text zu finden.
Könnte man sagen, das ist eine Auszeichnungssprache?
Nein, das ist keine Auszeichnungssprache.
Eine Musterbeschreibung.
Es ist ein regulärer Ausdruck. Also ich weiß auch gar nicht, warum die Dinger so heißen.
Erklär doch mal, was man damit machen kann, dann können sich die Leute das viel besser vorstellen.
Stell dir vor, du hast ein Hammer. Dann sieht jedes Problem aus wie ein Nagel. Das Problem ist nur, es gibt da draußen keine Nägel. Das ist Regular Expression.
Jetzt haben die alles verstanden.
Man kann zum Beispiel sowas machen wie such mir alles, was aussieht wie ein Wort, was mit einem großen Buchstaben anfängt und wo dahinter ein Leerzeichen und ein Komma ist, um es dann zu ersetzen durch dasselbe nochmal, aber das Leerzeichen vor dem Komma wird weggenommen. Sodass du so dieses typische ein Space vor dem Komma rausgenommen hast, aber du nicht die tausend Stellen, die du vielleicht auch noch in deinem Text hast, wo das Leerzeichen vor dem Komma echt wichtig ist, auch gleich noch mit wegbügeln. So eine Sache.
Ja, weil Advancedes suchen und ersetzen, also sozusagen innerhalb eines, in einer Zeile Text oder in einem ganzen Blumenstrauß von Text.
Du willst zum Beispiel alle Müller finden, egal ob die mit Ü oder UE geschrieben werden, sowas.
Auch, ja.
Oder du willst zum Beispiel wissen, ob das, was der User da eingegeben hat, eine valide E-Mail ist. Da muss zum Beispiel ein Ad-Zeichen drin vorkommen, da sollte eigentlich ein Punkt drin vorkommen. Wobei es geht auch ohne Punkt, aber das ist eine andere Story.
Naja, und das ist so beim Programmieren. Also eigentlich kommt man da nicht drum rum. JavaScript, Ruby, Python, Erlang, überall, wo man mit Text rummanschen muss und irgendwie Dinge so. Wir hatten ja über Pasa gesprochen, aber wenn man es halt nicht ganz so advanced braucht und wirklich zum Beispiel nur Timestamps aus einem Log-File raus extrahieren möchte oder URLs aus einem Log-File oder irgendwelche Teile halt nur. Und man will möglichst effizient darüber bügeln und sehr präziser sozusagen sagen, was man da genau raus haben will. Regular Expressions sind da überall. Und weil die halt so ein bisschen von der Schreibweise und der Syntax so ein bisschen kompliziert sind, gibt es glücklicherweise seit einigen Jahren schon so diverse Webseiten, wo man seine regulären Ausdrücke, die man sich so gerade ausgedacht hat, testen kann. Zum Beispiel eben so was wie ein Wort, was Tim gerade gesagt hat, was mit einem großen Buchstaben anfängt, dann kommt ein Bindestrich und dann 0 bis 3 Zahlen vielleicht noch hinten dran. Ja, wenn man jetzt nicht die regulären Ausdrücke oder die Sprache oder die Parameter mal reingefahren hat, was gibt es denn da überall? Dann gibt es halt auch noch ein paar Webseiten, wo man es ausprobieren kann und seinen String, den man hat, oder sein Stück Text reintun kann und den regulären Ausdruck dagegen testen kann. Und Tim hat das Thema Regular Expressions in die Show Notes geschrieben, weil er eine Seite ganz besonders toll fand.
Ja, die ist mir so vor die Nase gekommen. Ich habe jetzt nicht sehr viel Zeit damit verbracht, aber die fand ich in der Hinsicht schon mal ganz hilfreich. Die heißt REGEXR, also regexr.com. Version 2.0 steht da dran. Und naja, da kann man halt unten irgendeinen Text eingeben. Und da ist dann auch schon mal so ein Text schon mal da. Und oben gibt man die Regular Expressions ein. Und dann kann man sehen, was da quasi jetzt matcht. Also da sieht man auch sehr schön dieses generelle Konzept überhaupt bei Regular Expressions, dass man sich das überhaupt alles so denken muss mit, dass es so mehrere Orte gibt, auf das das jetzt zutrifft. Und dann wird irgendeine Aktion später genau diese Orte dann befallen.
Und das ist genau dieser Teil, der dann das Knobelspiel auch so spannend macht. So wenn man dann so zusammen irgendwie auch manchmal vorm Rechner sitzt und denkt so, ah, ich glaube ich weiß welchen regulären Ausdruck man verwenden kann, um diesen String, diesen Text zu finden. Und dann tippt man diesen Text, den man so hat da unten in das Suchfeld, ein und oben tippt man seinen regulären Ausdruck rein und dann sieht man, ob es passt oder nicht. Und dann kann man noch ein bisschen nachknobeln, ja, nee, muss ja hier nochmal und da nochmal.
Gab es da nicht so eine Regex-Kreuzwort-Rätsel?
Regex-Crosswords hatten wir glaube ich schon mal. Das ist so für die Advanced User. Also wenn man diese Einsteigerseiten, wenn man da anfängt zu gähnen, dann kann man wirklich noch mal sich auf das Kreuzwort-Rätsel mit Regular Expressions stürzen. Aber so zum Testen, Üben und Lernen vor allem von Regular Expressions ist das wirklich sehr gut. Weil das ist schon etwas, was man können sollte, wenn man so halbwegs literat mit dem Rechner unterwegs sein möchte. Command Line, Unix-Command Line, Regular Expressions.
Ach, alles alter Kram.
Das muss man können.
Und allerdings muss ich jetzt mal an der Stelle sagen, in FreeBSD voll schade. Also, nee, das ist nicht unbedingt ein FreeBSD-Problem. Hat Mac OS übrigens auch in der neuesten Version, haben sie bei Grep die Perl Regular Expressions rausgeschmissen.
Wer hat die Regular Expressions?
Na, in Grep auf Mac OS und FreeBSD gibt es keine Perl Regular Expressions. Da gab es ja dieses Minus P-Fleck mal. Weil die Perl Regular Expressions von der Programmiersprache Perl, die sind halt so ein bisschen fluffiger zu benutzen. Oder sind ein bisschen eingängiger, sagen wir mal. Und da muss man sich dann einen GNU-Grep installieren, damit man das hat. Die Begründung bei...
Die FreeBSD-Jungs haben was rausgeschmissen, dass man jetzt was mit GNU nehmen muss? Das ist ja sehr untypisch.
Ja, die haben halt gesagt, diese Regular Expression Implementierung, die Grep da benutzt, die ist halt... Die will man nicht mit Gummihandschuhen und Atemmaske anfassen. Und wir müssen das jetzt nochmal richtig machen. Und solange da dieser stinkender Müllhaufen von Kot da nur zur Verfügung steht, schmeißen wir den raus. Ja, das ist aber eine Anekdote am Rande nur. Ich habe ja eine Seite, die ich immer zum Regular Expression testen verwende. Tim? rubula.com, klick doch mal da drauf. Die kommt glaube ich aus der Ruby-Welt, wie der Name eventuell verraten möchte. Das Interface ist jetzt so ein bisschen, naja, ein bisschen kantiger. Aber es tut im Prinzip das gleiche und ich glaube im Vergleich...
Und du brauchst immer die Quick-Referenz da unten.
Genau. Ja, die ist auf jeden Fall ganz hilfreich. Aber was der gut macht und der andere irgendwie, habe ich zumindest nicht geschnallt, wie er das macht. Wenn du Back-Referenzes hast, dann zeigt er dir die da halt auch gleich alle schon an und nummeriert die durch und du siehst gleich irgendwie, wie deine Back-Referenzes funktionieren.
Also runde Klammern meistens.
Und das, ja, ich meine, das ist halt so ein bisschen kompakter, das Interface, aber funktioniert auch wunderbar, seit Jahren bewährt, hier testet Huckel höchstpersönlich seine Regular Expressions.
Genau, was mir dann auch noch vor die Nase geworfen wurde, was ich aber nicht getestet habe, ist debuggigs.com.
Das ist ja noch kantiger.
Das sieht aus, als wäre das mit XJS gemacht oder sowas.
Keine Ahnung. Aber es gibt da, sagen wir mal, für jede Geschmäcker irgendwas und alle haben so ihre Vor- und Nachteile. Und hier kann man, glaube ich, so zwischen Python, JavaScript und PCRE, also das normale Regular Expressions, hin und her schalten.
Also die meisten Sprachen heutzutage nehmen ja mal die Per Regular Expressions, Gott sei Dank.
Ist das PCRE eigentlich?
Aber wofür steht das C da drin?
Per Compatible, glaube ich. Das ist so eine Library, die man relativ einfach einbinden kann.
Also das Interface da sieht jetzt nicht so prickelnd aus, muss man sagen. Das sieht von Windows-Entwicklern gemacht aus.
Windows ist jetzt wieder cool.
Das sagtest du heute schon mal und ich habe nicht verstanden, was du mir sagen wolltest.
Tim wurde gebrainwashed, er war bei irgendeiner Marketingveranstaltung und da haben sie ihm was ins Getränk getan.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch nicht so schlecht, weil das hier irgendwie auch diese ganze Logik der Regular Expression selber noch mal visualisiert. Das kann man alles irgendwie mal ausprobieren und wer was gelernt hat, der kann sich ja melden. Nö, im Sinne von, wenn es funktioniert sozusagen.
Okay, hier hat jemand die Regex Crosswords noch mal ins Rennen geschmissen.
Und man muss dazu sagen, dass für ganz viele Sachen gibt es natürlich schon fertig Regular Expressions. Also zum Beispiel der berühmte Test für die E-Mail, da gibt es schon, da muss man nicht sich selber hinsetzen und auch noch gucken, was ein E-Mail nun haben muss und was nicht. Sondern da gibt es im Netz schon eine Menge Leute, die den Kopf sich schon mal gebrochen haben und dann klaut man sich das einfach.
Und vor allen Dingen E-Mails mit, also es gibt auch Dinge, die man nicht mit Regular Expressions validieren sollte. Also E-Mails sind ein Kandidat, weil es da so viele abstrakte Regeln gibt oder absurde Regeln gibt, wie eine E-Mail aussehen kann. Und es gab irgendwo, hatten wir glaube ich auch schon mal in der Sendung schon vor Ewigkeiten verlinkt, wo einer mal sich hingesetzt hat auf Stack Overflow und hat mal so richtig beides back. Was ist alles eine validierte E-Mail und wie sieht der kürzeste Regular Expression aus und es war halt auch so ein Blog.
Einer der coolsten E-Mails, die es gibt, ich weiß nicht, ob man es verraten sollte, aber ich glaube, das ist schon rum, aber es ist Dollar at US. Das ist eine valide E-Mail.
Also Dollar Zeichen oder was?
Ja, Dollar Zeichen at US ist eine valide E-Mail und kommt auch an und wenn man Pech hat, kriegt man vielleicht sogar eine Antwort, wenn man jetzt dahinschreibt. Und da will ich ja mal sehen, welcher Regular Expression Test denn die durchlässt und welche nicht.
Also was halt bei Regular Expressions ganz schnell passiert, dass man so ein Allmächtigkeitsgefühl bekommt, der so, aha, ich habe verstanden.
Ich habe jetzt alles im Griff.
Ah, E-Mail-Adresse validieren, kein Problem. Wort, Komma, Punkt. Ah ja, das kriegen wir auch noch. Adzeichen sicher. Und also E-Mail, da gibt es epische Diskussionen auf Stack Overflow, wo die Leute sich da total irgendwie verschießen mit ihren Regular Expressions. Ein anderer Klassiker ist natürlich HTML oder XML, irgendwie mit Regular Expressions zu parsen, parsen zu wollen oder irgendwie auseinandernehmen zu wollen. Ganz, ganz schlechte Idee, weil HTML, wie ihr alle wisst, ist generell in den meisten Fällen kaputt. Und da drauf...
Für XML gibt es Parser.
Naja, das sollte man wirklich mit Parser machen. IP-Adressen wird auch erstaunlich oft irgendwie komisch gelistet.
Ja, hat da auch einer im Chat schon gelistet hier, für IPv6 und so. Aber wie gesagt, so das Standard-Zeugs legt da gar nicht los, da sucht euch gleich was Fertiges.
Also, ich weiß nicht, irgendwo gab es mal eine Seite, wo auch einer meinte, pass mal auf, Jungs, mit Regular Expressions macht ihr das, aber das nicht. Also, Vorsicht, Kinas, wenn ihr das jetzt zum ersten Mal in die Hand nehmt, dieses Spielzeug, ihr seid nicht Gott. Auch wenn es sich so anfühlt. So, nächste Themenkarte darf gezogen werden.
Ja, ähm, aus der Abteilung, was ich bemerkenswert fand, und zwar flog mir so eine Nachricht um die Ohren, dass die NASA beschlossen hat, so rund 1000 Software-Projekte als Open Source freizugeben. Was ja schon mal an sich ganz interessant ist. Gibt's schon ein GNU-Mond-Flugprojekt? Was ich in diesem Artikel überhaupt noch als Information fand, was schon vor längerer Zeit stattgefunden hat, nämlich 2009, zum 40. Geburtstag der Apollo 11-Mission, haben sie nämlich auch den Source-Code der Apollo-Systeme, also des Raumfahrzeug und des Lunar Landers freigegeben.
Das ist wahrscheinlich Maschinencode für Prozessoren, die keiner mehr kennt, oder?
Das ist Maschinencode für einen Prozessor, der der Lunar Lander und dieses Raumfahrzeug ist. Damals wurden Computer noch spezifisch für Anwendungen gebaut. Das nennt sich dann einfach AGC und AGS. AGC war der Apollo Guidance Computer. Der Link ist in diesem Golem-Artikel.
Ich kann das hier noch mal gerne da her schmeißen.
Dann gibt es hier diesen entsprechenden Open-Source-Compiler dafür.
Da gibt es übrigens von Omega Tau. Das ist ja so ein Podcast, der mal gute und schlechte Episoden hat. Ich glaube, es sind sogar zwei Episoden zum Thema How the Americans flew to the Moon. Da hat irgendwie so ein Brite ein Buch darüber geschrieben. Und den hat er zwei Episoden lang interviewt. Und die sind wirklich gut. Also die kann ich echt empfehlen.
Hier ist Source Code auch verlinkt in der Seite. Da kann man sich das angucken. Das ist halt so Assembler. Das ist jetzt so 40 Jahre alter Assembler. Der ist jetzt so kompliziert nicht. Also die Maschine, ich habe es mir jetzt nicht komplett durchgelesen, aber ich meine, das ist halt überschaubare Komplexität. Das hat halt so ein paar Register und kann so ein paar Dinge. Und im Wesentlichen schreibst du da in so wenigen Kilobyte Speicher. Ich meine, das Ding hatte noch Core. Also Kernspeicher, verflechtete Ferritkerne nennt man. Das war der Speicher da. Nicht so Chip oder so mit hier irgendwie einen Megabyte.
Das hat natürlich auch den Grund, dass du dann nicht so anfällig bist gegen Strahlung.
Na ja, klar, so ein Chip wird schnell mal durchlöchert.
Ja, vor allen Dingen auf dem Mond bist du ja relativ weit weg vom Magnetfeld der Erde. Und da ist nichts mit Strahlenschutzschild durch Magnetfeld der Erde und so. Das muss schon strahlenhart sein. Und da bist du mit einem Ferrit-Kern, glaube ich, ganz gut aufgestellt.
Ja gut, ich glaube, mittlerweile sind sie von der Ferrit-Kern-Technologie auch weggekommen. Also ich glaube nicht, dass sie damit jetzt im Wesentlichen bei Langzeitmissionen arbeiten.
Nee, da sind sie natürlich schon weg.
Wie auch immer, was ich jetzt bemerkenswert daran fand, ist, erstens, dass sie das überhaupt tun, zweitens, dass man auch hier ein sehr schönes Anschauungs-Ding hat. Also ich finde, hier gibt es mal einen richtigen Grund, sich mal in diesen Assembler einzuarbeiten. Weil das ist einfach so Single-Purpose-Kram. Du hast halt einfach diese Maschine, du hast halt einfach diese Apollo-Maschine, die muss zum Mond. Und die komplette Komplexität dieses Systems ist in einer relativ überschaubaren Anzahl von Zahlen, Codes.
300 Zeilen Assembler-Code. Da sind einige Leerzeichen drin. Und am schönsten finde ich die Bemerkung.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der Code jetzt schon wirklich alles ist hier.
In der Episode von Omega Tau sprach der davon, dass die, wenn sie eine bestimmte Aufgabe lösen mussten, immer dem Rechner dann das entsprechende Programm erst mal geladen haben. Und das lief dann und dann konnte man da Zahlen eintippen und dann hat es irgendwas gemacht.
Wurde noch erklärt, was diese 300 Zeilen Assembler-Code da machen?
Na ja, da sind halt Comments drin. Oh really, ja, aber erklärt ist jetzt ein bisschen übertrieben.
So viel kann es ja nicht sein, ein 300 Zeilen Code.
Okay, der zweite Link führt zu ungefähr 1000 Zeilen. Na ja, 1400.
Na, ich kann es dir jetzt nicht genau erklären, deswegen werde ich es auch gar nicht erst probieren. Aber im Wesentlichen, also Sie haben, das ist die Aussage, Sie haben den ganzen Source Code veröffentlicht. Das heißt, da ist der komplette Code drin, der so ein Lunar Lander auf dem Lunar landen lässt.
Auf dem Lün, auf dem Lohn.
Auf dem Lün, auf der La Lüne. Und ich fand das lustig, weil als ich so mit Rechnern angefangen habe, und so in der Schule, was war denn so der heiße Scheiß, da war so diese, konnte man ja nicht so in die Schule mitnehmen. Aber ich hatte so ein Casio 1500 programmierbare Taschenrechnerkram. Die waren schon ganz fancy, weil die auch schon so, war das 1500?
Ich hatte einen Sharp EL 512, oder 512 ELS oder S, irgendwie so.
War das nicht Casio 1500? War das Sharp oder Casio?
Da hat jemand den Ausdruck digitalisiert.
Wie hießen denn diese? Das war nicht Casio. War das Sharp? Doch, vielleicht.
Mehr so, die hier so breitlich waren? Diese kleinen Minicomputer mit richtiger Tastatur?
Ja, genau. Hier so Sharp 1500. Genau. Und da gab es dann schon so, die hat man in Basic programmiert.
Oben hattest du die Übersicht. Wie viel RAM hatte der? 3,5. Immerhin. Der Sinclair ZX81 hatte nur 1 KB Speicher.
Und danach hast du eure Hausaufgaben dann mit programmiert?
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was ich damals damit gemacht habe oder wo ich den überhaupt nachher hatte.
Ich weiß genau, was ich mit meinem gemacht habe.
Aber da gab es irgendwie ein Mondlandungsspiel drauf. Und Lunar Lander war damals so das Generic Game, weil das konntest du in irgendeiner Form auf jedem, auf allem irgendwie zum Laufen bringen. Also hier war das zwar nicht so grafisch, sondern mehr so...
Es war so rundenbasiert, ne? Hat dir gesagt, wie hoch du bist, wie viel Treibstoff du noch hast. Und dann hast du eingegeben, wie viel Treibstoff du jetzt verbrauchen willst beim nächsten Burn und so weiter. Und dann hast du die, ja, ich weiß, die Richtung. Auf dem TRS 80 von meinem Vater hatten wir das auch mal abgetippt irgendwie und zum Laufen gekriegt.
Also es hat auf jeden Fall immer alle irgendwie total beschäftigt. Wie kriegt man diesen Lunar Lander jetzt wirklich auf die Oberfläche? Und jetzt gibt es den original Source Code. Das war jetzt schon ein paar Jahre her. Und wenn man cool ist, nimmt man diesen Simulator, lässt diese Software laufen und dann hat man wirklich the real thing, the real deal. Und das kann man ja dann irgendwie mal umschreiben. Also man kann ja die Programmlogik nehmen und in modern day Computing überführen. Also da kann man jetzt irgendwie mal eine JavaScript-Version draus machen und so. Aber man hätte sozusagen dieselben Controls. Man hätte dieselben Berechnungen, dieselben Inputs und am Ende natürlich auch im Idealfall dieselben Outputs.
Ja und dann lässt es auf einem Core i7 laufen und machst irgendwie 2000 Mondlandungen in der Sekunde oder was?
Das wäre zum Beispiel schon mal eine schöne Sache mit so viel mit mit Monden, mit unterschiedlicher Gravitation.
Aber wenn man das sieht, dann werden diese Mondverschwörungstheorien wieder realistischer. Also, dass die damit auf den Mond gelandet sind.
Man muss sich irgendwie auch klar machen, dass auch bevor alles schon so mit allen Bells und Whistles ausgestattet war und man irgendwie 3D-Berechnungen realtime machen konnte, dass eigentlich auch schon mit sehr wenig eine ganze Menge ging. Und dass so dieser lächerlich aussehende programmierbare Taschenrechner von 1982, 1969, wahrscheinlich irgendwie jeden Supercomputer…
Raketentechnologie.
Ja, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Computer waren einfach schon, war noch der Enabler für Raumfahrt an sich. Also die Berechnung selber auf Papier unmöglich.
Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an Ironsky, wo sie das Smartphone verwenden, um dieses Riesenraumschiff zu fliegen.
Na hier, ich meine, ich erinnere mich dunkel, als ich mich mal über die Geschichte der Computer und so informiert hatte, gelesen zu haben, dass die Computer dann verwendet wurden, um Raketenflugbahnen und so für Interkontinentalraketen zu berechnen und so. Das war ja bekannt und auch akzeptiertes Allgemeinwissen. Und dass sie früher Turnhallen voller Frauen hingesetzt haben, um die auszurechnen, weil sie dachten, dass die Frauen jetzt besonders genau beim Rechnen sind und das dann irgendwann nicht mehr so skaliert hat und dann eins aufs andere kam. Und wenn man dann Interkontinentalraketenflugbahnen mit digitalen Rechenmaschinen berechnet, dann ist ja die nächste Flugbahn, die halt ein bisschen weiter rausgeht. Schnell gemacht. Jetzt halt mal um den Planeten rum und so weiter und so fort. Das fand ich auch so verrückt, aber da hat man auch schon drüber gesprochen. Diese Sonder, wie ist die von der ESA, die jetzt diesen Kometen da chased?
Rosetta, die jetzt aktiviert ist.
Ja, da gab es ja so eine Webseite, ich glaube, die hatten wir auch verlinkt, wo man so die Flugbahnen, die komplette über die Zeit sehen kann. Das ist totaler Wahnsinn, wie die um die Erde, um den Mond, um die Sonne überall Schwung holt und dann am Ende genau diese Flugbahnen einschwenkt und jetzt da so hinterher schießt mit, was weiß ich.
Das finde ich auch so bemerkenswert, das mir war auch früher diese Dimension von Missionsplanung auch irgendwie nicht so klar. Du hast so dieses komplette Sonnensystem mit den paar Trabanten, die wir da eben haben und du willst jetzt zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt irgendwo hin mit einer bestimmten Geschwindigkeit in einer bestimmten Richtung, so in zehn Jahren.
Mit zwischendurch mal ein paar Monate so alles ausschalten.
Genau und vor allem, du willst den Weg, also du willst nicht nur einen Weg haben, der jetzt überhaupt erreichbar ist, sondern natürlich auch mit so wenig Treibstoff wie irgendwie möglich und außerdem möchtest du along the way auch noch möglichst viel sonstiges Zeug, was so rumfliegt, an dem man ja im Idealfall so vorbeifliegen könnte, auch noch mitnehmen. Und er hat ja irgendwie, Rosetta hat ja bis jetzt zu der aktuellen Phase auch zwei Beobachtungen von anderen Asteroiden vorgenommen, die sie einfach mal so eingebaut haben, weil die wissen ja irgendwie auch, wo der ganze Scheiß rumfliegt und das ist auch alles irre. Also gerade diese ganzen Asteroiden, die ja auch noch mitgetreckt werden, also insofern sind es nicht nur so ein paar Objekte, sondern es sind viele, ich weiß gar nicht, Tausende, wenn man alle Asteroiden mitrechnet wahrscheinlich, die da theoretisch in Frage kommen. Also nicht alle Asteroiden sind jetzt interessant beobachtet zu werden, die größeren natürlich nur. Aber die sind natürlich alle irgendwo und du musst halt dann das irgendwie so optimieren. Also du hast so viele Lösungsmöglichkeiten, so viele Parameter und so viele Optionen. Und da dann wirklich zu einem realistischen Szenario zu kommen, unter Berücksichtigung von Gravitationen, Sonnenausrichtungen.
Ich bin ja schon beim Autoscooter überfordert. Ja ehrlich, ich meine, wer ist, wann, also ich meine, ich bin jetzt bestimmt schon vor, wenn du mich das letzte Mal Autoscooter gefahren hast, bestimmt schon acht Jahre oder länger her. Wann bist du das letzte Mal Autoscooter gefahren? Du sitzt da so drüben und denkst ja, ok, alles unter Kontrolle, aber du vergisst halt auch irgendwie, dass dann so 20 andere Humpelmänner mit ihren Eltern teilweise noch so irgendwie nicht mit der Steuerung klarkommen und auf irgendwelchen komischen Kollisionskursen ohne Rückspiegel und so weiter und so fort. Und irgendwie stelle ich mir so, ich stelle mir dann so eine Mission quer durchs Universum, um Planeten rum und so weiter, stelle ich mir irgendwie so Autoscooter at large scale vor.
Ein bisschen mehr Platz ist schon. Aber diese Flyby-Manöver und dieser Scheiß, das muss schon.
Ja und vor allem das Ding, das soll dann erstmal schneller jetzt aufholen, dann um das Ding rumorbiten und das Ding ist viel groß, dieser Kommet so ein, zwei Kilometer oder irgendwie so ein Scheiß. Also jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel, also das ist vielleicht zehn sein, aber auch ist ja auch keine Größe so in dem Sinne und das Ding muss jetzt da noch dann im Vollspeed irgendwie dann sein, oh ja ok jetzt bin ich da, jetzt fange ich mal an hier so ein bisschen rumzukrisseln und dann natürlich noch irgendwas draufschießen und so weiter und so fort. Von einem scheiß riesen Stein, der da durchs Weltall schießt.
Schneeball. Ich guck grad mal, wie groß der eigentlich ist. Ja, ein dreckiger Schneeball. Der, was hat der für eine Größe? 5 mal 3 Kilometer.
Ja, freundlich.
Ja, aber für so Sonnensystemdimensionen, ja, Pipifucks.
Hat wahrscheinlich auch nicht so viel gravitative Anziehungskraft. Also da musst du schon sehr genau reinfliegen.
Wir hatten da schon mal drüber gesprochen. Hatten wir da über die ganze Mission gesprochen? Worüber haben wir denn gesprochen?
Ja, wir hatten auf jeden Fall über diese Webseite, da hatten wir erwähnt, dass das Ding aufgewacht ist.
Mittlerweile ist ja noch was passiert. Jetzt haben sie ja auch noch den Lander aktiviert. Das hat auch funktioniert. Also die sind da auf einem guten Weg.
Machen die eigentlich schon abgeschrieben oder was?
Nö, aber ich meine, die waren halt jetzt ein anderthalb Jahr ausgeschaltet. Und es gab genau gar keine Kommunikation.
Du meinst jetzt so ein bisschen, wenn man seinen Unix remote bootet und nicht weiß, was wiederkommt?
Genau, nachdem das Teil zehn Jahre im Keller gestanden hat. Und du remote den Strom anmachst.
Du musst damals alles richtig gemacht haben. Mit deinen damaligen Möglichkeiten.
Und du machst nicht den Remote den Strom an, sondern das Teil macht sich irgendwie den Strom an. Du hast da noch so einen kleinen Quarz dran kleben, der da irgendwie 15 Millionen Klick gemacht hat, bevor es wieder angeht.
Ja, und filet, so heißt dieser Lander, der soll ja dann wirklich auf diesem Teil landen. Und das ist schon echt...
Da gab es irgendwie so ein Lego Movie, wo sie das mal vorgeführt haben. Das fand ich sehr geil. Lego Movie? Ja, die haben den Lander in Lego nachgebaut und dann haben sie denen irgendwie gezeigt, wie das alles funktioniert.
Das gab es mal, das gibt es ja bestimmt immer noch.
Ja, das gibt es immer noch, aber...
Dieses Internet ist vergänglich. Eben noch eine Cloud jetzt schon in der Wunderkugel.
Ich würde sagen, gleich das Erste, was du da...
Was für eine Welt, ich meine, man gibt einen Rosetta, Lego und here we are. Das ist sogar von der ESA. Using Lego to simulate ESA's touchdown on a comet. So, jetzt müssen wir zu lange hier zu spielen, 19 Minuten. Uppsala, da kommt das Lego.
Ja, die trauen ja ganz viele Lego-Blocks. Dann haben sie das Teil in Lego nachgebaut und dann zeigen sie halt, wie das Ding, wie es funktionieren soll.
Das haben sie in den anderthalb Jahren gemacht, wo die Sonde ausgeschaltet war und nichts zu tun gab.
Ja, wobei die haben da eine Menge zu tun in der Zwischenzeit.
Das war ja auch nur so der Herkunft.
Oh man, ich hoffe, sie haben die ganzen Lego-Steine.
Die schütten da gerade Lego-Steine im Wert von einem zwei-Familien-Haus irgendwie hin, oder? Ich meine, um ehrlich zu sein, das kann sich doch kein Schwein leisten.
Das ist ganz schön teuer, Lego, oder?
Die baden da drin wie die Jakob et Duc. Nee, das kann keiner bezahlen.
Da gehen unsere Steuergelder hin.
Vielleicht sind die nur geliehen und gehen dann wieder zurück mit Lego oder so.
Das ist immer noch der Vorspann hier.
Du hast ja verstanden, dass das eigentlich in die Credits kommt.
Naja, wenn es 20 Minuten jetzt hat. Komm, mach mal aus.
Jetzt irgendwie...
Die Vorspulen.
Ja, ich...
Klick da mal irgendwo mitten drin rein.
Na, jetzt erklärt er doch irgendwas.
Da ist wahrscheinlich genau gar keine Erklärung.
As a scientist, I'm often asked, what is a comet? What's the point in studying them? The simplest way to think of a comet is analogous to an asteroid. Asteroids and comets are the rubble, the building blocks left over from the formation of the solar system, which due to interactions with the giant planets were unable to form the planets in their own right. The main difference between the asteroids and the comets is their composition, and this is driven by their location, their distance from the sun. The asteroids spend all of their lives near the sun, within the orbit of Jupiter. As such, they're composed of silicate rocks and metals.
Also jetzt bauen sie sozusagen die ganzen Elemente hier zusammen, ja. Ich spule mal ein bisschen vor.
Ja, da wo sie jetzt anfängt zu erklären, wie das Ding funktioniert.
Da so?
Ja, mach einfach.
Ich spule mal vorher.
Ah, jetzt haben sie einen kompletten Lander hier gebaut.
Das ist eine Lego-Modellrepräsentation des Lander-Filets, die wir nutzen, um einige Aspekte der Mission zu zeigen. Ist doch mal cool.
Jetzt landet er mit seinem Lego-Lander.
Guck da mal wieder auf größere Größe da.
Lego-Länder-Tai Chi.
Genau, und dann bohrt er sich mit seinen Dingern da rein.
Ja, nicht schlecht. Ich denke, wir schauen uns mal Videos an und der Rest hört zu. Aber kommt in die Show Notes und ist nett. Ja, das ist irgendwie eins dieser Outstanding-Projekte, die dieses Jahr stattfinden werden, die man irgendwie nicht genug erwähnen kann. Ich finde das irgendwie da wirklich bemerkenswert, weil das sind einfach so totale Firsts, die hat man halt nur einmal.
Ja, diesmal sind es die Europäer.
Tja, die sind auch gar nicht so uncool. Ich meine, die NASA hat ja jetzt das Problem, jetzt dürfen sie auch mit den Russen nicht mehr zusammenarbeiten. Das ist so.
Kann ja gar nicht sein, weil die Russen sind die einzigen, die Leute hoch und runter kriegen.
Ja, ISS ist auch das Einzige, was ausgenommen ist.
Also überall, wo wir sie nicht brauchen, schmeißen wir die Russen raus, aber da, wo wir sie brauchen, da arbeiten wir weiterhin mit denen zusammen. Ungefähr so zusammengefasst.
Naja, das Ding ist, brauchen tut man die Russen eigentlich überall.
Okay, wo können sie sie dann rausschmeißen? Der ATV tut es ja wohl noch nicht, oder?
Der ATV?
Den gibt es noch nicht als Kapselmodell für Raumfahrer.
So sieht es aus. Der bringt nur...
Ja, aber der wird ja entwickelt. Da sind die Russen jetzt auch nicht beteiligt.
Nee, aber ich meine, der wäre ja als Ersatz für die Russen, aber der ist halt noch nicht so weit, richtig? Das dauert noch ein bisschen. Von dem Tesla-Typen hier, dem Elon Musk, das SpaceX Grasshopper-Teil, was wieder hoch und runter fliegt.
Das soll dieses Jahr das erste Mal starten mit Landung.
Das war doch am 30. Oder? Warum gibt es da keine News?
Das war irgendwie verschoben worden.
Auf dem 30.
Vielleicht haben sie es normal verschoben.
Ich habe da nichts von gehört, dass das Ding hochgekommen sei.
Mal gucken bei Updates. Das letzte Update bei denen ist irgendwie 11. März. Die Falcon Heavy wollten so hoch schicken, irgendwie mit irgendeinem Zeug. Also ohne Menschen drin, ohne Astronauten. Aber die sollte hoch und wieder runter und landen, aber erst mal auf dem Wasser, sicherheitshalber usw. Weil sie noch nicht wissen, ob es klappt.
Hatten sie nicht diesen Versuch, das Teil irgendwie auf Land wieder zu landen, nicht schon gemacht?
Ja, aber das ist dann nur ein Kilometer hoch und wieder runter. Das war ja nicht richtig weg.
Das Ding kommt halt aus dem All zurück.
Ist schon eine andere Liga, weil es ein bisschen schneller landen. Da muss sich schon ein bisschen mehr bremsen.
Muss auch ein bisschen mehr Hitze aushalten zwischendurch.
Aber ist trotzdem schon erstaunlich, das Video, wo die so hoch geht und zur Seite und wieder zurück und wieder runter und sich wieder abstellt und die Flamme geht wieder aus. So ach nee, ich bleib dann doch mal hier.
Ja, wie im Science-Fiction.
Ja schon, oder? Also das ist schon nochmal eine andere Liga als alles andere.
Ja, das sah schon sehr absurd aus.
Ja, das kommt. Und, wo wollen wir jetzt gerade hinaus? Ach so, ja die Russen. Also, naja, ich meine, man kann natürlich jetzt aufhören, mit den Russen zusammenzuarbeiten, in einem bestimmten Maße. Also die Europäer können das sogar noch weniger als die Amerikaner. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Projekte die Amerikaner mit den Russen so wirklich am Laufen haben neben der ISS. Aber die Europäer sind da deutlich verzahnter mit der ESA. Also die ESA ist da deutlich verzahnter mit Roskosmos. Unter anderem ist ja auf dem europäischen Startplatz startet ja auch eine Soyuz. Also in Südamerika, da gibt es halt drei Raketen, nämlich die Ariane, die Soyuz und die Vega, die Letzten aus Italien.
Das ist so ein Feststoffding, ne? Ist aber doch auch eigentlich eine ESA-Rakete.
Ja, es ist ESA, aber es ist halt unter Führung der Italiener entwickelt worden und die Ariane ist halt die ESA-Rakete und die Soyuz ist halt die Soyuz, die halt einfach unheimlich gut abgehangene Technik darstellt.
Eine Entwicklungslinie seit Yuri Gagarin.
Das ist schon echt geil. Das ist das, was ich sagen will. Den Russen macht halt auch so schnell keiner was vor. Die haben da echt Ahnung und die haben das Thema nicht nur gut beackert, sondern sie sind vor allem auch oft ganz andere Wege gegangen als alle anderen. Und von daher haben sie einen unersetzlichen Fundus an Wissen in ihrer Organisation.
Angeblich hatten die aber zwischendrin Probleme, ihr Wissen tatsächlich zu bewahren.
Na, in den letzten Jahren gab es ja einen echten Tiefpunkt. Da sind ihnen ja wirklich alle Missionen kaputtgegangen. Das hatte da was mit dem Zusammenbrauch, der Sowjetunion zu tun. Da fehlt ja dann einfach der Nachwuchs, weil die irgendwie andere Sorgen haben. So ist das.
Ok, der Flug am 30. März wurde wohl verschoben.
Nochmal. Rescheduled.
Und mit keinem neuen Datum.
Das ist ja fast wie der BER.
Wie lasst mich raten, sind gerade nur Russen oben?
Wo wir gerade bei abgefahrenen Sachen sind, da gab es noch eine andere Meldung, die mir aufgefallen ist. Und zwar war das hier bei Heise. So über den aktuellen Trend im Schiffsdesign. Und die wollen jetzt quasi Schiffe, also Frachtschiffe, genauso steuern, wie sie das heute mit Drohnen in Afghanistan auch schon machen. Dass die Kapitäne überhaupt nicht mehr an Bord sind, sondern die sitzen einfach in so einer Simulatorkapsel. Und kriegen quasi...
In so einer Matrix-Schüssel in Salzwasser?
Ja, die kriegen...
What could possibly go wrong? Aber immerhin, die kann man dann nicht so einfach von Piraten kapern.
Oder noch einfacher, weil eh keiner mehr an Bord ist.
Naja, das ist, glaube ich, gar nicht so sehr das Ding, aber... Kannst dann halt die Kapitäne...
Also ein Kapitän kann mehrere Schiffe steuern.
Ja, ich...
Wozu brauchen wir überhaupt noch Kapitäne? Was kann ein Computer nicht, was irgendwie ein Kapitän könnte, sagen wir mal. Ja, das kann ja dann halt so ein Emergency-Rad machen, irgendwie immer. So viel werden es ja wohl kaum sein, aber das... Ich meine, die fahren das Ding eh nicht mehr von selbst, oder? So ein Ding ist wie viel Kilometer lang und wie viel tausend Tonnen. Da musst du doch eh berechnen, bis wann man zum Stehen kommt, oder? Das machen die doch nicht mehr im Kopf. Das läuft doch schon alles vorberechnet.
Also ein Bremsweg von fünf Kilometern ist wohl relativ kurz für ein Containerschiff. Und angeblich hast du normalerweise bei so GPS-Dingern in so Schiffen hast du den Man-Über-Bord-Button, sodass das Navigationssystem genau da einen Punkt setzt.
Wenn du anhältst, bist du schon fünf Kilometer weiter.
Genau.
Und diesen Punkt dann aber auch extra poliert mit Hilfe der Strömung, die gerade herrscht, sodass, wenn du dann deine 20 Kilometer Wendehammer gefahren bist, du dann auch wieder an die Stelle zurückkommst, wo tatsächlich der Man-Über-Bord gegangen ist.
Ja, beziehungsweise wo er jetzt sein müsste.
Wo er jetzt sein müsste, genau. Sonst findest du den nie wieder.
Ja, aber das ist doch mal eine interessante Vision. Ich meine, wenn du heute ein Seemann werden möchtest, zur See, dann fährst du in dein VR-Center und setzt dich da irgendwie in so ein Chipsimulator rein.
Oder es gibt halt immer noch Personal, so Handlanger an Deck, aber der Computer hat halt das Kommando und sagt so, ey Alter, hier, mach mal die Kippe aus und mach mal das Tau da fest.
Sie reden hier wirklich von unbemannten Fahren. Also, die wollen sich wohl die komplette Crew schenken.
Na ja. Wie viele Leute sind dann drauf auf so einem riesen Containerschiff?
Richtig kann ich mir das nicht vorstellen.
Ja, es gibt ja noch ein paar andere Argumente, die dir dafür sprechen. Die Dinger sind dann halt auch irgendwie nicht mehr körperbar.
Ja, wenn sie alles andere dicht machen, zu schweißen und so weiter, dann schon, ja.
Nee, ich mein, die kommen halt, es gibt halt überhaupt gar keine User-Accessible-Controlls.
Beziehungsweise, du kannst halt an Bord gehen, du kannst dann vielleicht mal den einen oder anderen Container aufmachen, aber du kannst nicht das Schiff zwingen, woanders hinzufahren.
Ja, aber das weiß ja schon, was die machen. Die docken einfach nebenan und laden alles rüber, lassen sich von dem Schiff sogar noch mitziehen, weil das fährt ja automatisch weiter.
Ja, aber dann kannst du halt auch so Selbstschuss anlagen und beliebige Springensitze, Ekeligkeiten und irgendwie flüssigen Teer. Also du kannst halt sozusagen jeden Scheiß machen, der ansonsten irgendwie überhaupt nicht drin wäre. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so ein ideales Target ist. Also ich würde sagen, es sieht da nicht so gut aus wie Piraten. Das scheint ja eh gerade so ein Trend zu sein.
Das ist halt aber was billigeres, irgendwie die paar Leute einsparen, die da mitfahren oder die ganzen Schussanlagen auf jedem Schiff zu installieren.
Ja, aber die Piraten, die kapern ja das ganze Schiff samt Mannschaft und...
Wollen Lösegeld.
Sie wollen ja den halt aus den Containern gar nicht. Da sind eh nur Badeenden drin.
Dem Owner sind zwar die Leute egal, aber sie dürfen ihm offiziell nicht egal sein. Und deswegen funktioniert der Spaß.
Na ja, da muss man erstmal abwarten, bis so ein Ding da ist. Aber kann schon sein, dass sie so was machen.
Und wenn es jetzt nicht irgendwie Wehrtechnik geladen hat oder so, sondern wirklich tatsächlich Quietsche-Entchen, hey, dann fehlt halt ein Container-Quietsche-Entchen. Scheiß drauf.
Ja, genau. Hauptsache, das Schiff geht irgendwie seinen Weg so. Aber ich meine, wenn die Piraten dann halt auf so einem Robotschiff sind, wo einfach nichts zu sehen ist. Das Ding besteht dann einfach nur noch aus Containern und komplett verrammelten allem. Was soll die da machen?
Na ja. Gegen die zehn Zentimeter dicke Stahlwand schießen. Also irgendwann muss so ein Schiff gewartet werden und so weiter. Da wird es schon immer noch Interfaces und Türchen und Maschinenraum.
Ja, aber die müssen in dem Moment ja nicht geöffnet sein. Die sind dann halt komplett verbarrikadiert und werden halt remote ein- und ausgeschaltet.
Und dann haben sie einen GPS-Interceptor dabei auf ihrem kleinen Boot. Und gaukeln dem Schiff jetzt mal lokal vor, dass es eigentlich ganz woanders hinfahren soll.
Die Schiffe haben aber bestimmt nicht nur GPS an Bord.
Also hier mit den Drohnen in Iran hast du ja auch gesehen.
Ja, aber du kannst mit vertretbarem Aufwand die Hürden so hochlegen, dass ich glaube, dass einfach der gemeine somalische Pirat da schon Schwierigkeiten hat, da noch mitzuhalten.
Du bist also ein starker Befürworter.
Auf der anderen Seite könnte das natürlich eine ganz andere Klasse von Piraten anlocken, die halt dann, weißt du, das OpenSSL-Exploits auf Containerschiffen auszunutzen. Es ist vielleicht dann auch nicht so aufwendig.
Wie das Schiff ist entführt, aber wir hatten noch Kanonen an Bord. Ja, aber wir hatten noch eine alte Software.
Weißt du, ich meine, du hast halt dann schnell andere Probleme. Du hast ja keine Crew mehr, die irgendwie entführt wird, aber das Schiff ist möglicherweise trotzdem weg.
Du meinst, der Pirat von Horde kommt so locker mit dem Ruderboot angefahren, zieht sein iPad und macht dann irgendwie diesen Tanker, Primoz fährt erstmal in den Hafen. Das ist natürlich ein anderes Szenario.
Parkt automatisch ein.
Ja, aber du kannst dann halt ohne Geiseln ganz andere Force starten. Also du kannst dann halt auch, wenn du weißt, der Tanker ist jetzt einfach mal entführt, dann kannst du halt sofort Hubschrauber-Einsatz machen und zwar so richtig.
Ja, bezweifle ich alles nicht. Also einerseits kann ich mir nicht so richtig vorstellen, dass du über Monate so ein Schiff völlig unbesatzt irgendwo durch die Gegend schickst. Also kann ich mir nicht so richtig vorstellen, aber vielleicht kriegen wir es ja hin. Auf der anderen Seite ist es natürlich, wenn du die Latte nur niedrig genug hängst, sodass es sich für die Piraten nicht mehr lohnt, dann lassen das Schiff natürlich in Ruhe, ist klar.
Auf jeden Fall kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass diese ganze Schiffsgeschichte an sich einen hohen Automatisierungsgrad hat. Und da sind sie jetzt wohl gerade, dass sie sich relativ sicher sind. Sie wissen jetzt immer, wo das Schiff ist, wo es hinguckt.
B, die wissen nicht mal, wo ihre Flugzeuge sind.
Eventuell kannst du halt auch so Sachen machen, wie du stattest das Ding komplett mit Solarzellen aus und fährst es mit Strom. Nachts hast du zwar keinen Strom, aber es ist egal. Wie lange das Teil unterwegs ist, sind ja keine Menschen drauf.
Das geht da nicht unbedingt um die Geschwindigkeit.
Die Solarzellen würden auch nicht reichen, um so ein schweres, dickes Teil da.
Ja, du würdest es schon, wie Roddy schon sagt, es würde fahren.
Es würde fahren, es würde langsam fahren.
Aber ob es sich gegen jede Strömung so durchsetzen kann, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht. Auf jeden Fall, naja.
Das sind auch richtige Tricks, Leute, diese Teile. Die fahren mit Schweröl.
Also der Schiffsverkehr von den paar hundert Schiffen, die so unser täglich Brot so durch die Gegend fahren, also es sind wahrscheinlich ja schon tausend, die machen mehr aus als der Autoverkehr.
Na, kannst du mal sehen.
Weltweit.
Das ist gar nicht so falsch. Wenn dabei SimCity nur drei Schiffe sind, das sind genau die drei Schiffe.
Gut.
Die einzige Sache, die so zurückhält, ist das Rechtliche.
Ja, die haben noch Microsoft, Windows, XP und es ist jetzt der Support geändert. Und deswegen ist es gerade on hold.
Ab heute gibt es keinen XP-Support mehr, war es so? Oder ab morgen? Heute ist der letzte Tag oder der erste, wo man keinen mehr hat.
Das heißt aber auch Internet Explorer 6 ist jetzt weg.
Außer in Niederland und was war das Schweden, die noch mal für viel Geld, Support-Extenden gekauft haben? Alle halt.
UK auch, glaube ich.
Jede Bank, die noch einen ATM hat.
So, ich fahre hier gleich vom Ast.
Du meinst, wir sind durch.
Ich bin durch.
Du bist durch.
Kann man auch alleine nach Hause fahren. Ach, dir alleine wäre das ja.
Ja, wir müssen es ja auch nicht immer so ewig treiben. Oder?
Über Ostern dann, wenn wir alle wohl erholt sind, dann machen wir 5 Stunden mal wieder.
Das ist ja eine Ansage.
Ach so, noch eine kleine Ansage, genau. Und zwar der Chaos Computer Club Berlin hat jetzt nicht nur donnerstags diesen offenen Donnerstag, sondern wir haben jetzt auch einen offenen Dienstag. Kann dann jeder kommen, nächsten Dienstag. Ja, jeder.
Auch?
Außer Presse.
Auch kim.com?
Wenn er will.
Wenn er sich traut. Die Verschwörungstheoretiker und Aluhets und so, die kommen ja auch alle. Und die holen sich dann halt immer ihre Dosis ab. Aber grundsätzlich können erst mal alle kommen. Also wir haben jetzt Dienstags und Donnerstags offen, so ab 18 Uhr rum.
Na, das ist doch schön.
Herrlich.
Wollen wir es dann zu Ende bringen? Ja, bitte. Okay, dann spiele ich hier mal die Schleife ein.
Schleifst du mal die Schleife ein?
Aber heute ist nicht alle Tage, wir kommen wieder.
Keine Frage.
Keine Frage. Und in zwei Wochen ist es schon soweit.
Tschüss.
Und wir sehen uns bald.
Also bei Mt. Mount Gox, die haben irgendwie 200.000 Bitcoin in der Ritze vom Sofa gefunden. Also bei Mount Gox, da war nie alles in Ordnung.
Der Trust-Level ist jetzt nicht so hoch.
Der Trust-Level bei Mount Gox, der ist glaub ich durch.
Ja, hat seinen Ruf weg.
Das ist echt ein geiler Laden, ne? Ich meine, Vertrauen, Vertrauen, Vertrauen, tu ich diesem ganzen System nicht.